[Music]
[Music]
on the first day of the new year the
semifinals and the air things monsters
will
be decided for two players it will be
the perfect start to 2021
getting to that final where the winner
takes some sixty
thousand dollars so a lot is at stake
welcome to the champions chess tour
welcome to my humble abode this time
i'll be playing from moscow but here's
where i live
[Music]
there's the old mouse i use for all the
other tournaments it can be a little bit
dark in here this is a crucial moment
now i think levon is bobbing faster than
ever
anchor i'll certainly try to be in
killer mode from the get-go for winning
is not enough i need some more
[Music]
the air things monsters is the first
major in the champions chess store and
it is now all about
getting to that final so guiding us
through the final day of semi-finals
women's grandmaster ivanka houska and
grandmaster david howell and david are
you feeling fresh and ready after new
year's celebrations
yeah it's a great start to the new year
um i'm hoping for more of the same
actually
we've had some exciting days of chess
and hopefully the players they're raring
to go
and event the players do you think they
will start feeling their nerves now
yeah definitely we are inching forward
ever closer to the big one the final and
definitely the players are going to be
feeling the heat
and in fact on that subject we do
actually have
some tweets earlier on as stated
exciting start of the year second and
last day of the semis with rachel
o'graph
now the only trouble with that tweet is
that he spelled exciting a little bit
incorrectly and it says
exiting instead he could have jinxed
himself that could be a crucial
crucial error by le von erroneous and we
also have a tweet from
maxine vachergraf who tweeted
well this is just a rough translation
but no choice
but to go so he's feeling excited he
knows he's got nothing to lose
so definitely a lot of action in store
david uh maximi has to make a comeback
he has to win
at least one gay game today what do you
expect from the frenchman
i think he's going to come out all guns
blazing he struggled yesterday in a way
aronian got the type of positions that
suit him
and vashil graf he just never got a
rhythm never got his chance to shine and
um he'll go all out attack today i think
yeah
losing the first semi-final match to
levon aronian
in the other one timor ajabov while he
finished off the year in perfect fashion
the semi-finals of the air things
masters started with taymor rajapov
packing a punch with his moves he made a
spectacular move sacrificing his bishop
he made it with one second left
sacrificed his bishop attacking the
white queen and attacking this pawn
if he had captured with the pawn this
would have walked into a checkmate
queen now traps the white king daniel
dubois
had to capture this bishop with his
queen and now we saw another queen enter
the board the
black queen and the black rook they were
too strong white's king eventually did
not survive
the other semi-final saw levon aronian
showing no mercy to his friend maxim
bashir lagrave
a great idea by levon bringing the king
across that king is going for that white
knight now
that king is going to hunt down the
white knight look at the bar here wow
it's uh almost up to three advantage for
lavonda i i think the computer is
sensing doom for that poor
creature on the left side of the board
oh dear
maxim has resigned we're just so
impressed by our play lavon i'm
surprised myself
but uh yeah i'm trying to take it easy
and
it seems to work will you celebrate all
the new year
not a long celebration something just to
pretend i'm a normal human being and
then just go back to my
sketch celebrating like a normal person
by ivanka do you think levon oronian
was mostly focusing on the second
semi-final match yesterday also
yeah i agree with that i think he is
going to be focusing on the chats the
new year celebrations can come
afterwards when he's gotten to the final
maybe even one of the air things masters
exactly yes
okay it is all about that now getting to
that final let's take a look at the
standings in the air things masters
so daniel dubo he beat world champion
magnus carlsen in the quarterfinals
but he is struggling against timor rajab
in the semi-finals
losing day one he needs to come back
winning today to take it to thai breaks
and so does
maxim vagiello grab losing day one
semi-final against levon aronian
maxim he has to win day two to take it
to thai breaks and david
if we do have those tie breaks what will
i look like
so if the scores are tied if they are
level
after today's matches we'll go to blitz
games a best of two blitz games time
will be slashed
players will have only five minutes on
the clock for the whole game
gaining only three seconds after every
move if after the two blitz games we are
still level
we'll go to armageddon chess white will
have five minutes black will have four
but white has to win
to progress to the final all right we
could have a dramatic ending
to this semi-final day and then tomorrow
we will start the final
and the winner will take home sixty
thousand dollars runner-up
forty thousand dollars and we will also
have a bronze medal fighter or
uh a game or uh match for the third
place so
important also for the two players who
are knocked out today but winner sixty
thousand dollars if i go that's a lot of
money even for these chess players yeah
that is a lot of money and we
also mustn't forget that the winner gets
that golden ticket to the grand final in
september next year
well this year actually yeah yeah right
we are in 2021
yes so everything to play for is so much
at stake
all right well david owl spending 2020
learning a new skill
in the end of 2020 we took him actually
skiing with
one of uh olympic gold medalist downhill
skiers
aksa lunzwinda we will show you
everything of that today here's a little
teaser or
what you can expect if you trick magnus
that'll be
the highlight of my life pretty much
okay do you know about castling
do you know what castling and this one
goes jumps over yes
if we put the horse here he can strike
them both what we want here is
to attack this guy and this guy
[Music]
okay uh i understand that
uh chess is relatively new to you
um yeah
you feel ready we're looking forward to
the parade
i can't even talk my legs are like jelly
[Music]
oh my legs are back feeling like jelly
again just watching that
and this was just a teaser so we will
have more of this later in the show and
we did see
leon watson i think maybe your buddy
david tweeting that you are a disaster
in the slopes
yes i don't think anyone's surprised to
know that it did not go well for me on
those slopes
well you did get to teach actually also
some chess he did play
world champion magnus cross and it's
going to be interesting to see what
happens there as well
a great game actually very entertaining
very entertaining okay well
um that was uh something that david
learned in 2020 now we are in
2021 finally done with the strange year
2020 and we did ask the chess players
what hopes they have for this new year
my wishes are that's a world functions
better
and that everyone starts taking better
decisions
to quote american startups to make the
world a better place
i hope that if this vaccine works in the
u.s we'll distribute it
to every part of the world i'm hoping
that life gets back to normal and people
will
get back their jobs and people will have
enough money again to pay the bills
the first thing is that the world
recovers somehow that's the main wish
actually i don't
really need anything else personally as
a chef player i'm hoping
that over the board jeff will come back
i hope that things will open up slowly
but surely and uh
we take you know all the good things
we've got this year and
integrate them into our life my wishes
that
2021 would not be worse than 2020.
alexander grisha as optimistic as always
yes
but the other players were pretty
optimistic yeah they were very kind of
very
generous with their thoughts i quite
liked it and david honestly
uh 2020 has actually been a good year
for for chess for chess players
yeah obviously difficult time for a lot
of people around the world but for chess
itself um we've all discovered that the
online format is fantastic for chess you
can play
people all around the world from your
own home and um
yeah especially for these top players
having this tour i think it's really
saved them and
it's given us all something to look
forward to do you think we'll take this
into 2021 as well your mankind
chess um in a big way is changing with
his online chores
yeah definitely i think 2020 did show us
david said this big online chess boom we
had the queen's gambit
and suddenly that we have a world that
is addicted to chess
and uh i'm just loving it and i
definitely think that it will continue
we can write that momentum
and we do hope that 2021 will be a super
year and we do have a new question of
the day like a little bit related
to that a little bit related to that we
do have a new question
and of course the winner will win one of
the air things devices
which uh you know measures the air
quality on the room
such a great price but our big question
of the day
which you can answer using the hashtag
chesschamps
is what superpower would you like to
have
so i know what i would like i would like
to read people's minds oh
well that would be scary though yes it
can be quite funny though
very funny but i still would just
imagine playing chess and you can hear
your opponent go i want to play that and
you're like no no would you would you
win
every chess game if you could read your
opponent's mind yes
pretty much yeah pretty much yeah pretty
much yeah especially the christopher
graham masters i would just love to
be able to hear what's going on their
mind whether they're in fact
just spewing out lots of variations or
whether it's actually something a little
bit more basic
so is this maybe a superpower that the
best chess players actually
sort of have david they are a little bit
able to read the mind of their opponents
definitely they know each other
so well they can predict things in
advance often five six moves in advance
if not more
um yeah there's definitely something
there that they uh
well a bit of a superpower they have and
we need to combat that somehow
i know that my superpower though
actually it's not really a super
i just wish i knew how to ski better
well we're going to see how david does
in the slopes
later in this broadcast should look
forward that it's it's a lot of fun for
us to watch
um all right well now it's all about the
chess it's all about the semi-finals and
qualifying
qualifying for that final players they
are sitting
all over the world these four players
remain clocks are ticking down to start
for maximizier
it's almost three o'clock and he is
facing levonoronian
it's a little bit later for him six
o'clock in the evening who should feel
the freshest and and
most ready here ivanka well i think it
all depends on something really basic
like when they had lunch because if
maxine and bachelor graft
had a little bit lunch late then he
might be having an afternoon slump
but i don't know that is the ideal time
to play and then we have
levon who is at 6 p.m i wouldn't
necessarily prefer to play at that time
but you can see that levon aronian and
taymor rajaboff are actually
killing it right now this is definitely
the time
this is the time timora jabo also six
o'clock for him
daniel dubo five o'clock and this is one
of the semi-final matches
daniel dubo facing team raj above and
timor he was the winner of the first
match yesterday's
day one semi-final and on illegal well
he needs to fight back today david
we've seen some fantastic chess from him
do you think he will be able
to get that when he needs to do dubov is
definitely capable
if he gets the type of position which
suits which suits him so that if he can
attack if he can sacrifice
if he can go for his opponent's king but
rajab the reason he's ahead
the secret to his success is that he
stopped dubois from getting his favorite
types of positions rajabov
he has that mind-reading superpower he's
stopping dubois from playing his game
did roger bro actually come into that
semi-final you might go with just the
perfect tactics
yeah he had the perfect game plan there
he did exactly
what david howell said you know he just
killed the game
got slight advantages and just made sure
that deboff could do
nothing all right and the other
semi-final match and the first game that
we will follow
will be between levon aronian and maxim
vagiela grab
we thought this would be a super tight
one david levonoronian though
so so strong in that first match yeah he
was so impressive
yesterday he was so impressive for the
whole tournament so far i live on
aronian uh maxine vashti the graph he
didn't ride his luck in a way to get
here to this stage
let's hope that somehow lady luckiness
is on his side today as well and they
have faced each other
many many times and on that if we look
at the head-to-head
it looks like maxim should be the
favorite yeah so we do see there
um on the screen they're head-to-head
scores in speed chess that includes
rapid and blitz games and
maxine rashford grav he's ahead in their
record he's got 20 wins and levon only
has 11.
but more importantly for levon two of
those wins came yesterday
maxine wasn't able to win any games
maxine has reason to believe
he can fight back but it won't be easy
is the one showing ivanka
that he's really getting this online
format in his rapid form
yeah his strategy has been amazing you
know really he's been
so much superior than le the maxine
vascular graph
but we have seen a big weakness and that
has been
that twice levon aronian has fallen into
maxine bachelor graf's tricks and traps
and i think maxim bashir graph has to
play to his strengths
he's a tricky guy by nature he needs to
sharpen up
and we see it here all the four players
they are ready to start in just a few
seconds the first game
in the second semi-final match and we
did see maximum vagiela grab with a
well funny sweater today levon aronian
always wearing some funny sweaters just
a black one today and the game has
started david
yes so ivanka mentioned maxine vazquel
grav needs to sharpen up he's looking
very sharp today
and he's going for a very sharp opening
as well maxine vachelagrav
playing his favorite opening as black
the opening he's known for
as black he's played this for 20 odd
years um
yeah maxine vazquez playing the grunfeld
defense as black and levon aronian
he will not be surprised he's played
these opening moves so quickly
maxime is a bit predictable in this
opening stage we see a trade of knights
very early on white is occupying the
center with some pawns
black is just aiming to get his king to
safety very early on like his aiming to
castle
shift his king over to the right there
black might be ahead in development
but he needs to fight back against white
center ivanka has nicknamed
levon aronian mr center he loves to
occupy that center the middle of the
board with pawns
um so maxine vazquez he needs to find a
way to fight back
uh meanwhile he has castled his king the
black king now
super safe it will come down to who can
develop their pieces quicker who can get
their pieces into the game
to active squares levonaronian back with
his crocodile ring on his finger
fighting to get to that final he only
needs four draws today actually to get
to the final
but we definitely can't expect maxim
marcia legrov to come fighting for that
when can we see that already in this
game
yes i think he's being principled he's
doing what he does best his favorite
opening and
that might give him those good emotions
those good feelings
once you get a position that you know
and that you like i think that gives you
a good
uh launch pad for the rest of the yeah
levon has been a very
interesting player to follow because
he's been very clever with his approach
because maximum vaccinath as we've
noticed tends to stick to the same
openings so that kind of information is
very visible to lavon and he keeps
tricking i feel like he's tricking
maximum vascular graft with his choices
he's not playing the main lines he's
going into things that he studied
and perhaps maxine bachelor graph has
having to remember all the information
yes and if we bring up the analysis
board we can say see a bit of an odd
move there by maximum vascular graph
black's last move was to just push this
pawn forward only one square
defending its fellow here in the center
actually the most common move and the
move that i've seen maxine vaschelagraff
played plenty of times before
is to push the pawn two squares look at
this central tension
all the pawns looking at each other in
the middle of the board things will open
up
things will get very exciting instead
maxine vashly grav choosing to push his
pawn only one square
it is a bit of a passive move and
instead he does
come up with a different idea he brings
his queen out look at this the queen
eyeing up the white king indirectly
there is a pawn in the way this pawn is
now undefended
maxine vessel graph he's going for
something a bit different because he's
trying to throw love on her own enough
balance
and uh who do you think will be
successful in this match do you think uh
maxine vazquez can do it
i think he's he's definitely capable he
can do it but aronian has been so
calm so confident maxine maybe
if i have any small criticism of him is
that he just played a bit too quickly
yesterday
he rushed past some important some
critical moments he had
some big big decisions to make and he
just played very quickly he just played
instantly
um if he can maybe control those nerves
um take pause at the right moment then
he will get some chances
yes and uh of course levon ironian is
actually quite the crowd favorite we
have a tweet
from whiteknight027 he says go
love aronian stay solid be practical and
create
new masterpieces win it all
i i do love the cheer that is behind
level on aronian and uh yeah
yeah he has a lot of fans and rightly so
he does create those masterpieces from
time to time levon aronian a very
creative player
he plays moves that we don't expect here
in the studio we try and predict the
player's moves try and get in their mind
sometimes
he often surprises us um often surprises
his opponents as well
um i've played him many times and it's
just hard to guess his moves and that's
the beauty
of it this he finds these rich positions
in chess and he always makes the most um
of
the potential of his pieces meanwhile
maxine vazquez there with his last move
developing the black knight the black
knight in the center of the board it
will head to a more active square
a bit later on i expect to see white now
castle with the white king
you should always do this in the game
get your king to safety early on
um black has already done that i expect
to see lev on auronian do that shortly
okay we have seen a trade of pawns first
and levon
again he surprises me as i mentioned the
queens have left the board we did see a
trade of pawns and now the
trade of queens as well this is level on
irony and trying to play
the play the match situation play the
match strategy that he must have planned
beforehand
getting the queens off eliminating as
much risk as possible at this early
stage now the queens are off the board
it's going to be harder for maximum
vascular growth to attack
um and that white king in the middle of
the board
it looks a bit vulnerable potentially
but at the moment
black doesn't have enough pieces ready
to jump forward and attack it
yeah under the play is getting ready i
do quite like a
maxim's outfit actually looks very smart
this jumper
apparently it's uh balanciaga so oh yeah
the the posh stuff ah well from paris
the frenchman
dressing very classy here it must be
very expensive he should
maybe he's hoping for those sixty
thousand dollars
one player who's famous for wearing
balanciaga is daniel dubov actually it's
kind of his go-to
it's his brand really yeah so oh these
posh
chess players indeed and um
yeah what's your favorite clothing brand
than david
primark i primark something affordable
any primark
anyone working at primark watching hello
no david no no no no no we can't have
any fast fashion here
yeah but actually there's there's
something to be said for
dressing up smart for when you're facing
you know a chess kind of it's such an
important chess game such as this
because it kind of puts you in the mood
and you mean
business and then in fact they say that
about working from home
you shouldn't just open up your laptop
and
uh in your pajamas you need to dress up
pretend you're at the office and
get motoring and i really like what
maxim's done
yeah and i was actually taught that by
an english grand master when i was
um making my debut for the england team
i just turned up to the first game i
think i was just wearing
jeans and a track suit and a track top
and um he told me you have to look
professional because then your opponents
will be scared of you as well
they'll think that you're in the mood to
kill and they know you're taking the
game seriously
very smart yeah i think that's just a
good tip for everyone if you feel good
if you feel focused and professional
you'll play better yeah and um yeah
meanwhile a few moves have been made on
the board
black has jumped forward with his knight
now launching forward as well with the
black bishop
um black's pieces are starting to slowly
creep forward
but at the moment the white king's still
feeling relatively safe and remember
kings
in the end game once queens have been
traded off the board kings love to be in
the center
kings are very active pieces in their
own right so maxine vachelagrav as black
he needs to try and make sure that the
white king is a weakness is a target
if he isn't is unable to prove that then
white's king i think will be a strength
and levon aronian with an extra pawn
in the center for white he will have the
long-term advantage
yeah and i have to say i really do feel
that maxine bachelor graph isn't really
playing
into his own strands you know he's been
super tricky he spots the traps just
like this
and we do know that lavonne ironian
loves to possess the center you give him
a position which he can control he just
excels in that and here i'm seeing that
okay white has that extra pawn in the
center as david mentions
and the king is very safe but he's
controlling the breakthrough
you know black cannot challenge this
beautiful pawn center and i'm thinking
that this just plays into lavon's hands
yeah so this pawn center it's like a
rock right now for white these two pawns
controlling everything
black would love to explode the position
open maybe push a pawn in the middle
uh just to exchange off white's dominant
pawn white's strongest
uh pawn at the front here but the
problem is this square is controlled by
three white pieces
white is preventing black from ever
breaking out and if he can't break out
then this bishop will be blocked it's
essentially biting against granite here
it's not doing too much and that is why
after a couple of moves um level of
rooney bringing his rook to this open
file
and maximize countering with a bishop in
the middle he wants to trade off this
knight potentially
so that he might get more control over
these central squares
all right should we expect more fire
when maxim has the white pieces is that
do you think that's the games you've
sort of looked to
that's where he's going to get those
wins he needs he needs to
maybe his mistake yesterday was actually
going into an opening where the queen's
left the board
earlier on um when he had the white
pieces in both of his white games
yesterday he failed to achieve
any type of attacking chances and the
type of attacking chances he loves and
thrives on and
maxim here maybe going for the same
strategy when he should be switching
things up he should be
forcing levon out of his comfort zone
maxime it does worry me slightly that
we've played 17 moves already that's
quite a lot of moves
and he's only spent a minute on the
clock again he's rushing these critical
decisions and
when i faced him he often gets great
positions but he just rushes
sometimes and misses those key moments
um his killer instinct is great
but when you rush it's impossible for
any human
um to kind of calculate to see
everything a hundred percent accurately
i think he's the only player we ever
sort of talked about having too much
time on the clock
it's just spending too little time yeah
the time is there to be used you don't
carry it over to the next game so you
might as well
you know dive deep into the position and
make sure you fully understand
everything
yeah i agree with you there david
because if you're not using your time
correctly then you're just going to look
over the position
calculate in superficial ways we saw
that maxim
lost his first game yesterday and that
was
just because he was playing too quickly
and he didn't take the time
to deep dive into the position and
figure out what needed to be done
and uh here it's here i'm slightly
concerned about the opening strategy
because i don't see
any problems at all with the white
position it's rock solid and it's
exactly what levon
wants and you have to remember
if levon draws that's it maxine bachelor
out
russian draft is actually loud he will
not be in the final instead he'll be
playing the match for third place
so if the match is drawn 2-2 yeah that's
it
it's tricky for lavon do you press on do
you try and win and take some risks or
do you just try and
say okay i'm happy with that two-two
draw today but is it
in chess like we often see in football
when a team
only needs a draw um they often go to
the defensive
side or even if they're up by one point
or one goal
they go defensive and then it changes
the other team scores the goals they
need
is it like that in chess as well that if
you go too defensive yes and you
actually might lose yes
it is it is the case in chess as well
you know you have a
but you've got to give your your
opponent the opportunity to go to
a passive you need them to do that you
need
to not give them a simple position where
the most natural moves are the best
moves
you've always got to present some kind
of choice and you do this and this is
where tamar rajabov has been
so clever you do this according to the
psychological framework of your opponent
so if you notice that they have a
tendency to play active well you shut
down the position and you kind of
invite them to go forward if you notice
that they are
passive then what you do there is you
just kind of
you know you provoke them a little bit
and you say would you like to play
defensively
or would you like to take the risk and
most of the time if they don't take the
risk
then that's it you've gotten away with
something
and with this move david is is mexican
taking any or live on taking any sort of
risks
um no big risk yet but an ambitious move
by levon aronian
he's planted the white bishop deep in uh
black territory there
the white bishop potentially eyeing up
the black knight that black knight is
protected by a pawn so that would just
be a fair trade i'm not sure that lev
nerone in his idea is actually to
capture the black knight
with his bishop but that white bishop is
actually a thorn in black side
um that white bishop is actually very
hard to evict from
um black territory we do see maximum
vacuum push this pawn and
this bishop is gonna be hard to get rid
of look at this bishop it's protected
by white's rook on the open line black's
ideal in an ideal world black would move
his rook across
um and attack this white bishop but even
if he does that it is protected by the
white rook it's going to be very hard to
kick that piece away
maxine vashly grav playing instantly
again but i think he should be pausing
he should be coming up with a plan
of how to get rid of this white bishop
all right and it is lavon aronian he is
thinking again when maximum has over 13
minutes left on his clock
lavon is down to nine minutes so he is
he's spending his time
wisely or is he thinking too much i
think
he's he's okay for now on the clock um
he's spending time he's thinking ahead
and then we see actually he does go for
a controversial trade
that is controversial because that
bishop as david said was a thorn
and are we seeing some nerves
yeah maybe we're just seeing levon at
his creative best surprising us again
normally we say that bishops especially
in these relatively open positions
lots of open lines lots of open
diagonals bishops are quite strong
pieces
so to trade it off for that black knight
which wasn't doing too much
just there that's a big decision but on
the plus side
white now has a better pawn structure
white's pawns
are more fluid than blacks look at those
black pawns on the left side there those
two black pawns they are doubled
that means they've lost a lot of
flexibility and they will not be able to
protect each other
actually long term so long term that is
a good decision to live on ironian but
short term
the black bishops might become a
nuisance very very committal
i think maybe live on ironian he did
realize okay he's five minutes down on
the clock now
he did slightly panic there he didn't
need to make that decision i think so
quickly
and white's king now moving across
maxine vashti grav meanwhile leaning
forward and frowning
he's surprised as well i think by lev on
levon aroni's decision
yeah i i'm totally surprised you know i
was waxing lyrical about
lebron's position saying how easy it was
to play and that i didn't think that
levon
were maxine maxine was actually giving
lavon
enough chance to go wrong but i'm not
really liking the trend
of the play yes black has some double
pawns but
those two bishops that black have this
is
exactly what maxim wants and you can see
him
retreating the dark square the dark
bishop
and uh well lavon is just fight going
for a kind of wall right
yeah those white pawns um with levon
aronian's
last move he's put all of his pawns on
the right side of the board on dark
squares
and you notice this is actually quite a
clever strategic decision
white just traded off his dark squared
bishop
therefore he in order to control the
dark squares he has to put his pawns
on that color complex he needs to block
out black's dark squared bishop
that's a very kind of sensible decision
when you have allowed a bishop to be
exchanged put your pawns
on the color that you no longer control
so white has this light squared bishop
and the rest of the pawns
or most of the rest of the pawns are on
dark squares sensible play
by levon aronian but maxime he needs to
get his rooks active
he needs to get his dark square bishop
active if black can activate that dark
squad bishop next to the black king
then i i would start to love black's
position and finally thinking along
uh thinking for a long time as well a
minute paul's there for maximum vagina
so he's listening to you david he's i
mean spending one minute for me that's
uh like the blink of an eye for him that
is an eternity and um
he does play another sensible move
bringing the black rook towards the
center
those rooks love the open lines and
levon aronian starts to remaneuver his
knight
around he's going to go towards that
left side target black's double pawn
what's happening to the bar here
yeah well this is the thing what did
levon do he went backwards and you know
what i'm going to say here when you go
backwards i go forwards and so i'm
really expecting maximum rational
to now go forward with the pawn and
challenge that white santa because like
david said time and time again he's got
to activate that dark square bishop he's
got to get that one motoring
you know black has two long range
amazing weapons
and they need to get firing yes bishops
they are actually these black bishops
they're on the perfect diagonals this
bishop controls the long diagonal
this bishop controls the long diagonal
you need to just open things up and
that's why maxine russian grav he's
pushed this pawn open
we mentioned this is the spearhead of
white's structure this pawn
needs to be i mean just got rid of this
white point it needs to be traded off to
open up
this dark squared bishop and that's why
maximum ashley grav with this last move
uh offering this pawn trade here in the
middle if white captures look at these
black bishops suddenly this bishop has
come to life
this white rook in the corner is almost
trapped suddenly
and the trend is turning in black's
favor level ronin he needs to find a way
to stop this black bishop from becoming
active
wow it would be very cool for us and for
the match if
maxim got a win in this one then we
would be heading to tie breaks uh
after the first game yes and um
okay we do see that pawn trade in the
middle white's rook wasn't quite trapped
it does shuffle across
but those black bishops are looking
beautiful right now
maxine vegeta graph he needs to come up
with another plan maybe it's time to
start creating targets okay he plays a
move instantly a bit of a mysterious
move
just dropping back that dark squared
bishop he's playing so quickly
um i think his position has actually
improved over the last
four or five turns but just the fact
that he's rushing
um maybe he it was worth just investing
a minute or two there just coming up
with a bit of a longer term plan
he's just retreating his bishop there
i'm not so impressed by that last move
it's uh it's a very intriguing position
you know you have these two beautiful
bishops that black has against her
white's wall of pawns
um difficult to kind of see an inroad
but uh do you think do you think maxim
can do it can generate play
i'd like to think so um at least at
least create a position where levon is
forced to be accurate maybe
um levano at the moment he's being just
super solid all of white's pieces in
those first three ranks
uh just kind of huddled together um as
maxime i'd like to think that he'll try
and
find a way to maybe create a target to
create some kind of complications a bit
later on to maybe create a pawn race
um yeah as you mentioned your vanco
won't be easy white is super solid
but yeah you can see uh
levon haronian has moved his rook and
he's
inched it one square and immediately my
kind of tactical eye
is drawn to the fact that the two rooks
are on the same
diagonal as each other and that's the
kind of the first thing that i'm like oh
look at that i can perhaps pin a rook
but a case sadly it is covered by the
knight and we
see that maxim is trying to make his
inroad he's advancing a pawn
and he's trying to get that space yeah
so maxine
just pushing forward on that left side
in anticipation
of a pawn race a bit later on it makes
sense as long as you're not creating any
weaknesses with your pawn pushers
remember pawns don't move backwards
as long as you don't create any
wheathers you might as well push forward
especially in the end game because it
means that later on when things start to
happen when things
quicken up when they liven up your pawns
will be slightly
more ready to dart towards the end of
the board to try and become a new queen
that pawn also controls some very
important squares i like that last move
by vacheron graf meanwhile ironian
lining up his rooks together
that looks dangerous i think when you
have the two rooks in the same line
yes that's actually an ideal position in
general for rooks when they're lined up
together
but at the moment those two rooks
they're eyeing up one of black's bishops
but that black bishop it is anchored it
is protected
by a pawn so white cannot capture that
bishop
because the rook would be more valuable
there despite those bishops looking
pretty strong
so the white rooks kind of uh well they
were looking at that bishop
black meanwhile protects the bishop he
over protects it with his
rook maybe maxine vacherograph has got
the same idea as white he wants to bring
his other rook the rook in the top left
corner
to swing it across and line up his own
rooks um this one
is heating up slowly maxine bachelor he
is
activating his pieces it just looks like
maybe levon aronian
um that time deficit it might start to
become a factor he's now five minutes
down on the clock
and he does push a pawn on the right
side i i'm slightly surprised by that i
thought white's formation was perfect
on that right side um it shows levon
aronian maybe he's just
not sure what else to do he's going to
slowly start to push forward why didn't
he push that point two squares
so that it would be protected by the two
other pawns good question
um i would have been very attracted to a
move like that um maybe he just wants to
blunt the effect
of uh black's light squared bishop um
sometimes if you feel your opponent's
bishops are too strong you just need to
bl
block them or need to blunt them with
your pawns
yeah a bit of a mysterious one by levon
he needed to play a move quickly
yes yeah you have to sometimes with
pawns you have to be very careful with
advancing them you know i
you know i'm quite advocate of being
gung-ho and just advancing them but you
do
have to think about them because they
can't retreat and once
you advance the porn you have to be on
the lookout for something called holes
and these are pieces these are squares
that can be occupied by pieces
and i what i'm seeing here is i'm seeing
that lavon wants to
really very slowly not giving his
opponent
any chance for any holes to just advance
his pawns in the center but he's going
to do it like one step at a time
so it's almost like that kind of
caterpillar you know just imagine it
inching forward and it's just kind of
saying i'm being flexible
but as david says once that pawn has
advanced that's it he can't be retreated
so you know levon has to think about the
risks involved
and it's a really really tense position
because
i don't think the plan is necessarily
that clear for black
because all the all the white top
potential targets are kind of covered
and it's not that easy for whites to
come to come up with a plan for anything
because
any poor move that he does make he
perhaps lengthens the squirt
the diagonals of one bishop yeah um
note that everything in white's camp is
actually protected right now maybe apart
from that corner porn
uh on that right side um personally
especially grav i would be
just maybe trying to improve some pieces
here it's not obvious as ivanka
mentioned what the immediate plan is
so if there's no immediate plan then
just talk to your pieces ask which one
is uh kind of least happy right now i
would start improving that black rook in
the top left corner
and bring that towards the center maybe
just stepping forward with the black
king
just bringing it to a slightly more
active square
outside of the eye line of white's
bishop
there's lots of choice for maximum
vascular growth that's why he's slowed
down slightly
his time advantage is slowly
disappearing um
that's a good thing it is a good thing
that means he's coming up with this
long-term plan
he's just thinking which pieces need to
improve uh need to be improved how to
create those holes that ivanka was
mentioning
how to create those holes in white's
camp and meanwhile vashti de grav comes
up with
maybe one of the most ambitious plans in
the position
pushing that pawn yet again on that left
side
um he's gaining even more space but now
we do see a trade
um black's bishop is disappears but the
white knight
also uh leaves the board and white's
pawns in the middle look at those white
pawns in front of the white king
they are doubled they are weak they
cannot protect each other and meanwhile
maximum grav he's planted a bishop to
block those two white rooks
those two are rooks as you mentioned kai
they look so good looks so dangerous
um they are now completely blocked off
it's a very very unusual choice to kind
of see
one side voluntarily we i honestly
thought that porn
little pool move was there to support a
pawn advance because i was thinking of
actually pushing forward but uh levon
has a completely different idea in mind
he just wants to
lock the position down to get the
situation where you have opposite collar
bishops on the board
and black has gonna has planted his
bishop
blocking those double rooks and i think
white is going to do the absolute
same thing i think that he's going to do
the same with the bishop and
just to kind of come forward and it's uh
i think it's very risky actually i think
this is a very risky approach because uh
those two double pawns are lit
oh okay and we that's a big decision
we have seen a pawn sacrifice by white
pushing forward with this central pawn
attacking the black rook but this pawn
it can be captured
by the black bishop the black bishop
could snap that pawn off the board the
reason
levon aronian has sacrificed that pawn
is to liberate these white rooks these
white rooks suddenly become very
powerful
white could just drop a rook up the
board look at this attacking this pawn
attacking this pawn rooks are beautiful
on this line we call it the seventh rank
deep in the heart of an uh enemy
territory
um maxine rashford said no i'm too
scared to capture this pawn this pawn
was attacking the black rook so the
blackrook
has sidestepped meanwhile will this pawn
be a weakness
it is on a dark square it could be
captured long term
or can levon ironian justify the fact
that he's pushed this pawn forward
maybe he'll start pushing forward with
his bishop as well lining his bishop up
against the black rooks this is a very
tense situation
levon aronian going under five minutes
shortly he needs to justify
pushing that pawn on the last turn okay
exciting stuff and we do see in the
other semi-final
we have the other game going down in
bottom of the screen and it looks like
team rojaba who won the first semifinal
match
is uh getting off to a very good start
in the first game here as well
so exciting to see what happens there as
well but we do have some moves here
david
yes yes and a very intelligent play by a
lavon ironian totally unexpected
in my opinion but it is a master class
actually he has looked at his light
square bishop and he's gone right
where are you pointing to you're
pointing to that pawn on the right side
so therefore i'm gonna pile up my rooks
i'm gonna pile up every single piece i
have i'm gonna have maximum activity
uh very instructive play but you know
both players
definitely everything to play for and uh
a lot of support for both players as
well on twitter we
also have a tweet from francis iii who
says
let's go vacher legrove you can do this
and yeah he's certainly going to have to
dig deep because
lavon ironian has just advanced his pawn
and those bishops are going to start to
tell
yes and we do see white's strong central
pawn
march forward it did get taken off and
wow
a huge move a surprising move i did not
see this one by level ronin
he's actually sacrificed his rook short
term um
this we have to bring up the analysis
board this rook is just put itself
on an undefended square um the white
rook here
can be captured by the black bishop it's
just sacrificed itself but again if the
black bishop disappears
if it takes this rook he has opened up
the other white rook
this white rook is zooming down we
mentioned this seventh heaven the
seventh
line this is the ideal scenario for a
rook
um this is something that maybe maximum
vascular graph he should avoid so
after levon ironian dropped his rook in
this position he should just
ignore the fact that this pawn will drop
he should just let it go
um i would personally just be moving my
king out of the eye line of this bishop
this white bishop is just too strong
right now
um that was a surprising move by levon
these guys are so good at finding these
ideas
and like saying he didn't take it no he
didn't take it and now he's going to
take it so he's trying to make some
trade
you have to remember if the rooks get
swapped off that is it the game
will almost virtually and in a draw and
so that's why
if lavone ronian wants to push for the
win then he's going to have to do it
with the rooks on the board
and i actually attended like a master
class of one of our team
john ludwig hammer he was talking about
this type of ending where you have
rooks and against our opposite color
bishops he said they're not necessarily
that drawn it's all about the mini
plan and you've got to have stages in
mind so you've got to think about first
of all
i'm gonna i've got to have my plan and
in this case i think levrone's plan
would be
he has one extra pawn in the center that
is the guy that he's gonna
push so and then he has to control the
counter play
from black because if that rook at the
black rook gets active then it can be
such a nuisance oh okay
we are going to see a trade yes
i've seen the rooks leave the board
level ronin as ivanka mentioned maybe he
could have played for the win by keeping
the rooks on the board
but he was happy because of the match
situation remember he won yesterday's
mini match
um he's happy to guide the game towards
the draw the rooks have left and now we
see the bishops
look at the colours of those bishops
black's bishop on dark squares
white's bishop on light squares they'll
just balance each other out
each side will just control one color
complex neither side can really push a
pawn to the end of the board they will
just be blockaded
white central pawn there it will be
blockaded on dark squares um
both sides will have a blockade this one
should be a draw now
there's just no way to break through for
either side
yes i always like think of ships in the
night you know just
passing each other never ever to meet
with these opposite colored bishops
i think i think it was boris baskey who
used that analogy to describe
his ex-wife
they were like opposite-colored bishops
and we do have a draw in this game maxim
barcelo with the black pieces not able
to get the win he needs
in the first game here so he's going to
come out fighting probably in the next
the second game where he has the white
pieces now it's super interesting i hear
in the other semi-final first game
between daniel dubov
and timor ajaba what is happening here
yes this one is wild right now the last
game we saw it went straight to the end
game lots and lots of trades
this one most of the pieces remain on
the board
um this one is very hard to evaluate one
thing i always do when i look at a new
position
is i do a quick count a material count a
pawn count i count the pieces
and here i see that black is actually
ahead by a pawn
also one thing i noticed is that white's
king is still in the middle
white's king hasn't castled white's king
will always be a target
the reason we like to put our king on
one side of the board is because it can
only be attacked from one side
if you keep it in the middle it can be
attacked from the right the left through
the middle
through the center that is why black has
the advantage right now his extra pawn
and his safer king um rajabov moving his
rook there to the middle of the board
still tense still a lot of tension left
still a lot of life left
in the position as well but daniel dubov
he needs to somehow
find compensation for his ex ex-report
he needs to somehow whip up
an attack against the black king
otherwise long-term
uh he will be struggling yeah he'll
definitely agree with you there that
david he
has to go forward he has to create some
kind of attack
and one of the kind of things that we
actually saw him fail
yesterday he lost one of his games
because he didn't actually move his
pieces forward because sometimes when
you're a position like this
where you you know that long term you're
gonna lose
one kind of tactic to get out of it is
actually to do something that i know
that chessable
author uh davis merden calls window
ledging
and the whole kind of concept is that
you know when you have a
you're you've got your back against the
wall and someone is definitely
going to impale you or kill you or
something
uh you kind of hop out of the window and
you go onto a window ledge
and the point is if you carry on on that
window lid you're going to escape
but you know if they follow you then
suddenly
it's there's a lot of risk involved and
they have to find the precise way to
follow so
i think the only way to do this is just
to maximize the pieces um
duboff has to create chaos yes and
daniel dubov he's just shuffled his rook
across one square there he's
indirectly eyeing up that black king
we've mentioned he loves to go for the
opponent's king he loves to whip up
these attacks but actually it does look
like that maybe wasn't the most accurate
move
timor raj above he's i mean he's only
got a minute and a half left
but he has a massive advantage here um
actually if we bring up the analysis
board i think the move we're looking
here for here from timor rajabov
is to bring this bishop this black
bishop is currently not doing too much
to bring it to the side of the board
attacking this pawn it's undefended and
indirectly as well maybe attacking the
white king this would give black a
winning advantage
maybe there are other moves as well but
uh timor rajab if he plays this
he should win the game wow okay so we
are looking for this
bishop move by timor rajabo probably
here or might be getting a
perfect start to 2021 why he's he hasn't
played it
he has moved the queen and the queen is
now attacking the knight
so this is great news for dubois because
there really is only one move to
consider and i think that's just
retreating that night
so he doesn't have to give too much
thought about it retreat the night
and relocate that knight from the edge
of the board where it really wasn't
doing too much
and uh on to greener pastures yeah and
i agree with ivanka that should be an
easy decision and he does make it it did
cost him a little bit of time though
um that should be the type of move he
could play immediately
without thinking so maybe daniel dubois
just a bit of doubt in his mind here
but that white knight is on a better
square it's heading towards better
squares
timor rajabov may be showing a bit of
nerves for the first time
in this game in this matchup not going
for the most direct
the most brutal way to push forward his
advantage he should go in the attack
instead he's allowing white to
reactivate his pieces
and now just below the player's cameras
we do see the computer
uh evaluations the computer suggestions
for moves and
black he should still go for that bishop
move he should still bring his bishop to
the edge
attack that pawn try to get at the white
king um
it's not easy to find though especially
with 20 seconds he's not found it and
he has 30 seconds left on the clock and
we know when the play is reached 30
seconds
and less it is just panic it is not good
news
and uh i'm gonna i'm gonna guess that
things are gonna go wrong actually for
two for rajab yeah he panics there that
is not a good move white's bishop in the
center of the board he's trying to trade
it off
which makes some sense um that white
bishop is extremely strong
but um team rajabov he lost a lot of his
advantage there
with that last move suddenly he is the
one being attacked white's knight
jumping forward to attack one of black's
rooks um
daniel dubois he must be starting to
feel slightly more confident about the
way
this game is going the trend of the game
he had
i mean a position with just no hope
pretty much he would have been a pawn
down on the defensive
but instead now at least he's being able
to go forward that white knight
jumping um and timor rajab ignores the
attack
against the black rook he with that last
move his queen
the black queen is attacking white's
rook there at the bottom left corner
um counter attacking move there by timor
rajabov he made it with only 13 seconds
left on his clock he's
very low on time now um but there's a
move though there is a big move in the
position because white is attacking the
black rook
he cannot take that rook immediately but
he does
have a capture on the board i think we
should bring it up i think
you know it's super exciting because
white can now actually
pick up that rook and take the bishop
yes and white can take this bishop
sacrificing his rook for a bishop
that's a five point for three-point
trade giving up material but at the end
there's this killer move pushing the
pawn up with a double attack
attacking the black queen attacking the
black rook will daniel dubois see this
um this would actually give white a big
big advantage
if white were to capture this bishop um
the game would go on but
timor rajab he would panic he would just
have to play on a piece down remember
his other rook is also attacked
so many pieces being attacked he has so
much going on but daniel dubois he has
to find this move
he hasn't found it he did not fight he
missed it he did not look for the checks
the captures and the attacks
ah what a missed opportunity and uh
now rajabov has moved the rook and it's
actually impossible to advance that pawn
that a central pawn forking the rook and
queen world that black bishop is on the
board
pointing oh yeah that black bishop was
potentially
an important attacker against the white
king that is why as your vancouver we
should have just taken that bishop off
the board
and dealt with the consequences later
instead now it's very difficult for
daniel dubov
he did look maybe a bit too calm a bit
too relaxed um when
that was the critical moment he didn't
quite sense that that was his
opportunity to really turn the game
around and now timor rajabov
moving his rook forward out of the
attack of the white knight
again the onus is back on white now to
justify being a pawn down
and it's not easy to find a move um
okay and again another mysterious move
duboff has just picked up his rook
and moved it look at the bar there yeah
the bar hates it and i
don't like it um you know i can i feel
like i'm
being slightly critical on these
world-class players but i really don't
like it because
this is a messy position and you cannot
afford
just defensive moves like this you need
to create chaos
yeah daniel dubois he's an attacking
player remember he wants to be on the
offensive
attacking his opponent's pieces going
for the opponent's king but he's playing
on the defensive now
look at that daniel dubois trying to
trade queens a queen trade will not help
him and there we see a rook sacrificed
by timor rajabov
going for the kill now he has spotted a
checkmating idea
um actually i think that's the winning
move from timor raj above
why does the bar hate it why is it just
wow
the computer needed a while there to
crunch the numbers to realize that that
is a winning sacrifice and
actually that black rook could not be
taken we'll explain that a bit later on
the play is very low on time now
and white's king had to sidestep that
check
black now is two pawns up he could also
just trade the queens there we go
um once the queens have left the board
black's two pawn advantage
will start to make itself felt um two
more raj above
i mean he's almost home and dry in this
game he just needs to make sure that
the technical phase just keep everything
protected
and maintain that two-point advantage
and he will win as black yeah only with
20 seconds on the clock though is it
hard to find those moves that he needs
to find
now the queens are off it's easier yes
exactly and and the only thing is he
still has to keep a lid or we've seen
or we've seen dubois be extremely
dynamic and extremely dangerous he just
has to keep a lid on that momentum
and he'll be home dry so now
that we see it he is uh keeping that lid
on the momentum by trading a set of
rooks as well
white is just running out of ammunition
white is running out of uh
pieces simply um to even create some
threats to create some
scary moments for timor raj above black
there
still two pawns ahead um white's bishop
at the edge of the board is just not
doing anything right now
white's rook is very passive it's on a
defensive square it's not
on these open lines that we love to see
rooks on
white's king as well not a great piece
right now white does have one strong
knight
but this two-pawn deficit it it's it's
too much and also just look at how
composed this uh
rajaboth is he uh and to quote uh
raphael batista on twitter
he says raja buff is using the force
for sure he's a jedi master
and yeah just look at him he's
completely in control he does not look
flustered even though he has 46 seconds
left on the clock
he knows what he has to do and a win
would be a fantastic start we can almost
see roger
perhaps winning this match in two games
yeah timor
skywalker there just uh yeah calmly
guiding his advantage home and daniel
dubois doesn't
try to improve the white king that white
king though it is still cut off it can't
jump for
it can't step forward anymore that black
rook cutting off the white king
um okay the black road does step back
actually
going for white's pawn at the edge of
the board there going for uh white's
pawn
on the right side of the board that pawn
is lacking defenses it's lacking back up
um daniel dubois he's trying his best to
activate his pieces but you can tell on
his face there
he knew um he well he still knows that
he's up against it
he needs a bit of a miracle um one pawn
in an endgame
sometimes isn't decisive you can maybe
sacrifice a piece for that pawn later
you can just try and eliminate all the
pawns but the problem for
white here is that black has an
advantage on both flanks if you look at
the right side of the board
black has a two versus one pawn
advantage and on the other side on the
left side black has a three versus two
advantage um he will get outnumbered on
both of those flanks a bit later on
uh meanwhile timor rajabov just
re-centralizing his rook
very sensible play all of black's pieces
there looking nicely
coordinated controlling lots of
importance yeah definitely
and now it's just the case of mobilizing
all the pieces
and you can see rajabov taking care with
the king
um again that ro that white rook if it
could
get active cause some nuisance it's
gonna be okay but uh
okay i can't see it i can't see a way to
get active and you can see dubois
has actually signaled the retreat he's
retreated with the knights
and attacking the pawn but we're going
to see further trailer pawns
yeah and actually on both flanks now on
both sides of the board black has a two
versus one pawn advantage
so long term those two will start
marching down they will conquer that one
and they will outnumber white pawns um
so dana dubois he needs to do something
quickly
he needs to find some targets that is
why the white knight jumps up to the
board he's attacking a
black pawn now on the top left um that
black pawn it could just step forward
there's just no real danger here daniel
dubois he's just setting one move
threats he's hoping that either rajabov
doesn't see it or it causes him to panic
but rajabov he will see that that pawn
is attacked he will find a way to deal
with it
um he is pausing though both players
short some time there we see
black stepping forward with that pawn
and now white
he's lining up his rook with two of
black's pieces he's attacking the black
bishop
and kind of x-ray vision against that
black knight as well
um timor rajabov he looked down he's
just trying to calculate something he
hasn't blundered
he's still got it under control but he's
using his jedi mind tricks
he's closing his eyes he's just using
the force to
guide his pieces towards the best
squares yeah i actually don't think he
spotted that move and
now he's uh figuring a way out wow
what a move by timor rajabov um he's
sacrificing his bishop temporarily
um but the white rook i think it just
has to capture that bishop
um there's not much else to do right now
um okay
we will see this happen on the board
white did capture that bishop and now we
see a night for
a night fork black's knight attacking
white's rook
also attacking the white bishop one of
those pieces will drop off
um white chooses to save the rook the
bishop drops off the board
white's king steps forward but every
trade we see
guides rajabov slowly closer to his
angle
um in this uh in this very simplified
position now the black knight under
attack
should just retreat maybe um he could
also defend it with the pawn
lots of choice again by rajabov he knows
he's close but under 20 seconds again
that is the only thing that will stop
him in this game wow all right it is
looking good for timor
rajabov and he did move his knight here
yes and black's knight in the center now
threatening maybe another night fork
knights are so tricky with these double
attacks the black knight is
going to try and jump up next to the
black rook and give check to the white
king also attacking the white rook
um this is why night when you're low on
time especially in these
quick games rapid and blitz chess
knights they can cause havoc
you can walk into all sorts of forks all
sorts of double attacks
um the white king now is right in the
center of the board attacking the black
rook
attacking the black knight uh two more
roger bob he will have foreseen this
though yeah he will definitely have paul
seen it
and okay he has his pick of moves he can
move the rooks and offer a trade
he can also move the knight and attack
the rook and we've just seen it on the
board now
so the rook will have to move and once
that rook moves
well white well black will snaffle up
the rook
and uh yeah yeah white shoes wow what a
move
white chooses not to move his rope so
impressive yeah we do see the
trade of rooks there black sacrificing
his rook but now capturing the white
rook with his knight as you asker says
so impressive so calm as well
it's so tricky with knights on the board
but he's navigated these treacherous
waters
very very well there rajabov he's very
close to his goal now
still with two extra pawns it's like
that maths equation it was such a
complicated
i mean there were so many numbers so
many pieces on the board he simplified
it right down
so it's all about just the knights and
just the pawns now you have four seconds
though he has to make a move he cannot
let the wind slip
so the knight has gone to the edge and
it's all going to be about that pawn
on the right hand side that is past porn
or as the norwegians say free pawn which
i just love and there he goes
it is on the run and it's going to start
making its way
to become a queen it's going to get to
the edge it's got no rival now
that that black pawn is going to start
marching down the board
it's there and so you're gonna expect
the white the white king to try to play
catch up and
this allows well this allows the knight
to
hop in and again start munching on some
bones yeah and the one thing we
always say about knights is that they're
terrible on the edge of the board the
other thing about knights is that
they're not very good at stopping
these corner pawns because knights they
love to be in the center where they
control all the squares they struggle to
stop these corner pawns
because they can only stop them from one
side of the board that is why black has
been pushing
on that right flank and that's why he's
going for white's other corner pawn
once he eliminates that he will
eliminate all risk rajabov still under
control this one
white's king now trying to edge towards
black's corner pawn
that corner point can be given back up
though
uh black's king can start marching
forward to support it black has another
pawn on that side
that can also just snack on the pawn on
the left side of the board
lots of choices by raj above but okay
well he he has advanced
his pawn there's this pawn cannot be
taken though because
if he takes the pawn with the king then
the pawn on the right side will just
start running all the way to the edge so
this is why raj above
uh dubois sorry has refused this offer
and instead
moved the king one step closer but
perhaps he's gone a little bit wrong
yes maybe maybe it's gone slightly wrong
for timor rajabov just over the last
couple of moves he knew he was
completely winning
um he knew he had those two extra pawns
now he's only down to one extra pawn
and he's re-centralized his knight maybe
he just forgot to take that pawn
on the left flank four seconds david
three two
one okay we've also seen fragile play on
the edge when it comes to time you know
we've seen him make moves with one
second left on the clock
and yeah he did put his head in his
hands just momentarily there losing that
jedi focus
um the black king stepping forward but
white's knight if it can recentralize
itself
and come over to the aid of the white
king on that right flank
maybe daniel dubov can save this game
there's still a chance remember
if white can sacrifice his knight for
all of black's remaining pawns if he
only leaves black
with a knight for the game will be a
draw a night on its own is not enough to
deliver checkmate
and that is why daniel dubois he's going
after black's pawns now
with his knight um timor roger maybe he
missed that last move
that black pawn on the left flank it
might not survive
um okay white's stepping forward with
his king he's going to try and eliminate
all of the remaining pawns
maybe he simplified the maths equation
too much um down to zero
and um this one it's still
black still in charge he needs to try
and keep some pawns but
daniel dubov he has fought bravely like
a lion
just trying to save this game yes and uh
i'm fully expecting there to be some
more trades because we mentioned it
yesterday
that when you're in a worse position you
should trade the pawns and not the
pieces
and i'm fully expecting duboff to
actually advance his pawn on the right
side
just push it forward and just offer some
more trades because
like david says the target is and he's
seeing it there the target is to get
into a position
where black has just the knight and uh
white has some pawns
yeah and if we do see a set of pawns
leave the board on that right side
timor raj above his winning chances will
start to dwindle and start to disappear
oh
is this a blunder that looks like it it
looks like it because it allowed
it's a horrible blunder by daniel dubois
it allows him pawns to move forward and
uh he needed to keep an eye on that pawn
that was gonna start advancing yeah this
is why we don't like to get low on time
why only had two legal moves he was in
check he only had two squares for his
king
it was a 50 50 chance but he chose the
wrong one and
he just forgot to blockade the corner
pawn we talked about the corner porn
earlier
knights are so bad at stopping it kings
also sometimes struggled to stop those
corner pawns
um and now black should be winning yes
he finds the winning move those two
black pawns supporting each other now
um they will decide the game he got so
close to a draw there
he just put his king on the wrong square
wow and taking time to have some tea or
coffee there timora jabo
he was losing his advantage and suddenly
it's back
yes and it's all to do with those
connected past pawns he you know
it was really unforgivable that dubois
just allowed
himself well he just allowed rajabov to
just advance those pawns
ever so slightly forward and that was
deadly
and white gave check there with his
knight he's desperately trying to bring
his knight back to that right side to
stop the pawns
but black's king is trying to shoulder
that night away he's trying to block off
that night's retreat
and that's why daniel duval has to find
his night uh has to place his knight
on a bad square but i think uh timor raj
above
as long as he doesn't lose on time he
will win this game the black knight now
supporting the advance of those pawns
i expect to see the corner pawn push
forward one square away from becoming a
queen now
and the other pawn will push forward
just using that teamwork
um black ever so close to that goal ever
so close to making another queen
oh but seven seconds okay he moved his
pawn yeah look at that white king it's
so
overworked it's lonely over there on the
right bottom right corner
just outnumbered by the black pawns and
the black knight and all black needs to
do is just use the teamwork to start
pushing those pawns even more further
you know i think i'm expecting the the
black knight now to get more actively
involved and
also the black king and there's just
really nothing to be done
yeah white's king is completely frozen
it could not capture the night because
then
black's porn would become a new queen so
he tries to bring his knight back into
the action
look at that white king now it's
actually trapped all what all black
needs to do is bring his king forward
um and actually he's found an even
better move
he's using his knight he's going to
control the corner square next move that
knight is going to give check to the
white king black's going to make a new
queen and dubois resigns
he gives up he's fought so bravely
so close but then he blew it just at the
end what a dramatic start to day two
semi-finals for daniel
dubo he needed a win instead he loses
and team raja but wow he is definitely
heading for that final now
yeah he's right on course um daniel
dubois he just needs to get his type of
position
he needs to be on the attack not the
defensive timor rajabov a master of
psychology here
dominating his younger opponent yeah and
to win with the black pieces as well
that is just shocking
you know you have to say if roger brock
manages to win with the white pieces
that is it it will be rajib in the final
and david i don't even know
sort of where we should analyze this
game but because there was so much drama
roller coaster again this game where was
it decided eventually
so the game the early stages of this
game
um timor rajabov came up with a killer
move that daniel dubov had actually
missed
daniel dubov with his last move offering
this queen trade
trying to get the queens off the board
and this move i didn't expect it
it was a big shock to me a huge shock to
daniel duval black sacrificed his rook
on a square that looks very well
protected black used his rook
to take this pawn giving check to the
king it looks like this is a blunder at
first
giving up the black rook but timor rajab
had seen four moves ahead he'd seen a
forced checkmate
the black queen drops herself down to
give check to the white king
remember the queen is defended by the
rook the king only has one square the
king could
jump forward that would give another
check attacking the white king the white
king only has one move again
and then the black rook would come down
and a bit of teamwork here the black
queen and the black rook give checkmate
the black
the white king is completely trapped
nothing to do this would be game over
and that is how rajabov he did win a
pawn after he played this rook capture a
bit earlier on
capturing this pawn with his rook he
went two pawns up and we saw
eventually that told he did give dubois
some chances to save the game
but eventually rajabov's extra pawns did
the business
wow is this um super impressive by team
rajab obviously but or is it
just um daniel duvo not playing his best
chess here
i i think it's all unreliable rajapov
has been extremely good he
is so good psychologically and uh
absolutely i i think uh duboff is on the
back foot
[Music]
it could all be decided in the next game
between teamwork
and danielle dewbo if rajabo wins that
game it's all over for dubo he is out
and rajabo will be going through to the
air things masters
final and this is the
the standings after the first game in
the second semi-final match
that needs revolved losing in a crucial
game to team or
jabo he needs to win he needs to come
back winning
the nil dubo or else he could be out if
rajabo wins that
then maxim bachelor playing a draw in
their first game and their second game
has
actually started and like same well he
needs to get a win
in that match-up wow well dramatic start
to the day
already ivanka absolutely unexpected
you know for roger bob to defeat do go
up with the black pieces
this is a really turn up for the books
he is on the verge of going through to
the final
and of course lebron ironian and mexi
investor graph well that's not the idea
for maximum bachelor graph he wanted to
put pressure on levon
and that hasn't happened so far dubo
with uh the black pieces in the next
game
he's got 15 minutes to prepare for that
one what should he do david
he needs to just be having a complete
rethink of his strategy he
needs to at all costs find that type of
position where he can attack
and we saw it against magnus carlsen
when duboff gets a way to attack his
opponent's king he's deadly
he'll take every chance he can get but
um maybe he just needs to have a chat
with one of his friends one of his
coaches just to snap him out of this
funk
just to tell him okay stop playing into
your opponent's hands
rajab he's too good in these long
strategic positions all right it is
getting dramatic in the semi-finals of
their things monster now
we're going to have some fun um as we
mentioned earlier
david has met up with the world champion
in downhill skiing
olympic gold med medalist norwegian
downhills gear axel
swindoll he is a fantastic downhill
skier retired now but he did get a lot
of gold medals when he was active
but a chess player he is not a chess
player david
messed up with him the plan was for for
axel to teach
david skiing but first of all david was
going to teach axel
to play chess before he was going to
play a game
against magnus carlsen
we're here today at snow and i'm very
excited i'm going to be meeting axel
lundsvindale
a norwegian olympic medalist at alpine
skiing
i'm actually a bit terrified as well as
you see behind
it's a big slope and i'm british i
haven't skied much in my life
luckily we're going to be playing some
chess first spindle is actually going to
play against
magnus carlsen later what carlson
doesn't know
is that i'm going to train svindal
carlson will never know what hit him
so i'm not a chess player at all okay
but suddenly you're jumping in at the
deep end and playing the world champion
later that's
yeah exactly it's pretty very it's um
well i mean i guess you're here to hold
my hand so that's why it feels
somewhat safe if you trick magnus
that'll be the highlight of my life
pretty much
okay just kind of teach you a few things
about what you should be aiming for in
the beginning of the game
okay let's start with that actually okay
so there's three things to remember in
the beginning like
control the center ideally with a pawn
then develop some pieces and then get
the king to safety
do you know about castling castling
and this one goes jumps over yes these
uh what towers what do you call them
yeah
rooks rooks if we move this guy then
this guy has some protection
actually yeah but with this opening
there's no way he
could have gotten me to chess he can't
protect you nearly no matter what he
does yeah so this
is also a part of our strategy exactly
[Music]
i was told when i was young nights
before bishops tonight on the rim
is dim if we put the horse here he can
strike them both
what we want here is to attack this guy
and this guy
the question is how deep into action do
we get him
how brave
let's go back to the beginning again
okay uh i understand that
uh chess is um
relatively new to you um
yeah i have a lot more time than you
have so um
yeah you have plenty of plenty of time
to think plenty of time to talk
okay so i'll do my best at doing both
we'll start yeah that's a good first
move
if you could attack that knight that
would be would be good for you
yeah but i can but then you have a horse
there i see but i can attack it with
uh something else maybe hold on
well
remember what i told you
control the center nights
before bishop get your kick to safety
nope no that wasn't it that was a
horrible move
this is a move that neither defends
any pieces nor attacks any pieces it's a
good rule for
for life as well if you do things that
are
are inherently purposeless then that's
not a good idea
if you have a purpose let's move in life
doesn't seem very motivating no oh i
forgot that i have a little time
actually i'm
nervous which just like makes no sense
whatsoever
you have the chance to win that night
back
don't talk too much but now i'm coming
for you i'll give a check
this is not awesome
so now the conclusion is very near
it is and there you have it
that's the checkmate
okay i can't say that i saw it coming
but uh
i mean i saw some pieces moving into the
corner but uh i didn't see the checkmate
coming
you sir survived a lot longer than bill
gates for instance
okay that's actually probably the
highest praise that i've ever gotten
wow auxillium swindal playing against
magnus crawls and ivanka are you
impressed with both how axel did
obviously losing to magnus and and david
teaching him yeah david was a natural
wasn't he um yeah i was a bit
unfortunate with
axel making that blunder it was a little
case of
knowledges it's a bit more dangerous and
no knowledge because i'm sure he
wouldn't have touched that night yeah
if david hadn't said nights before
bishops
it's all my fault you're right always
playing the coach
i guess this was the fun part of the day
for you david teaching him the chat yeah
and actually i was really impressed um
as he mentioned he's quite new to chess
and he picked things up really quickly
um maybe his downfall was the fact that
he hadn't actually played online before
and he didn't really realize that he had
a lot more time
to really spend enough time and he said
that magnus was clever
using mind tricks to distract him with
all the talking and he did say
before that game that his aim was
actually to do better than bill gates
playing magnus carlson a few years ago
only lasting for
a few seconds in a blitz game against
magnus and
and oxen just new to chess he did last
for a lot longer
yes that is the benchmark for every
celebrity playing chess you gotta last
longer than nine moves
and axel uh well bill gates lost in
nightmares axel survived 18 so he's
twice as good as bill gates fantastic
all right um
we are going to show the second part of
this day later in the broadcast where
axel they it was turned around and axel
was teaching david
to ski so uh we're looking forward to
that now
this was all organized together with air
things the device that can monitor
air quality in your house and and the
air thing is also
prized in our question of the day today
iowanka it is
definitely a prize it's gonna monitor
the air quality in your room i'm super
excited that i have one in the post
and our quiz of the day it is
what super power would you like to have
the more interesting the better
of course i would like mind uh mind
reading
yes mind reading but uh i have to say
there was a great uh program once it was
a comedy program where this girl
actually got the ability to mind read
and she mind read that the dog and the
dog really liked her i was like oh i
love you
and she's like i don't want this power
so of course uh
any any interesting powers that you'd
love to have the more fascinating the
more out there
you know the better the better and we'll
feature them on the show yeah i would
like the classic
to be able to fly i think that would be
amazing okay i think daniel dubo
he's gonna want to just win that next
game
because that is what it is all about for
him now we will follow now in the next
one the game
between the nildubov and timur rajabo
and the status is
that if team rajabov wins this next game
he will be in the final it will be all
over so dubo
at least needs a draw in hope um
to take it all the way and to take it to
tie breaks but
i mean preferably with white pieces he's
gonna want to
with the black pieces he wants to win
david and
i mean head to head here it's very tight
between these two
it is very tight but remember timor
rajabov
actually before this semi-final he was
behind
it's just the fact that he's won three
games against daniel dubov
in the semi-final without reply so the
trend is in rajabos favorite
favor their recent history does favor
him daniel dubov
he just needs to remember that he is
capable he did knock out the world
champion magnus carlsen
he can do it but he needs something a
bit different what's going to be team or
job of the strategy in this next game
ivanka with the white pieces is it going
for that wind to just end it or do you
think he's gonna go for the draw
i think he's just gonna play normal
chess you know see what has to be done
over the chessboard he knows that the
pressure is on duboff he's
super experienced and he's well we've
seen it
he's like a mind jedi isn't he he's
playing so calm so
focused he is actually my favorite now
to win the air things masters
impressive wow and we know now david it
is not just another chess game now
so much at stake in this next game how
will mentality and nerves be for them
now
yeah i think both players will feel a
bit nervous i mean rajabov he hides it
very well that's the key
um do both may be showing those nerves
with his moves with those blunders
that we've seen um more for rajabov it's
just more of the same for dubov
he just needs to channel that same
energy remember that he did beat magnus
carson he can beat the best in the world
it's just finding that kind of vibe
finding that rhythm
and getting into it we are getting close
to that uh
um could be the final game in the
semi-final between rajabov and
daniel dubo if rajabo wins that game wow
i'm getting super excited for this one
i'm so excited to see if rajabo with the
white pieces will go for the win and
the the second game in the semifinal
between maximum vacillagraph and
lebonroni and it is being played right
now they already started
their second game and we know what needs
to happen there as well
maximizier lagrange needs to get a win
at some point
the first game ending in a draw and
timor um and we see daniel dubom
already ready he's eating something
getting maybe the blood sugar
up we are waiting for team or a job of
uh i think actually
daniel dubo he looks well he looks calm
and ready
ah he's wearing his lucky balenciaga a
lot of balenciaga
uh commercial in this picture right now
we know that also my sim sweater is
that brand yes and uh daniel dubois
he's he is stocking up on those snacks
he needs that energy a bit later in
games
um remember his blunder in that last
game it came right near the end
deep deep into the game so maybe he's
just lacking in that extra energy it is
it is close to evening time now over in
russia
so he needs to make sure that he find
keeps that stamina
to take his chances if and when they
come timo rajabov meanwhile
um that looks like a comfy chair yeah
he's sitting in maybe that's another
secret to why he's been so impressive
this week
we are waiting for timor jabo that chair
we know he said he started playing some
online games as well computer games uh
counter-strike i think he said he was
playing
turns out it's good training for him
yeah everyone
i think in life not just in chess
everyone needs a way to switch off and
relax and
whatever rajab's doing is working for
him yeah well he's not
here yet we are waiting for the second
game could be the decisive game
in the semi-final between rajabo and
dubo
well rajabo has still not shown up for
the game
daniel dubo is waiting for him planning
what
can is it easy for daniel dubo to
expect what rajabo will choose is rajab
one of those players with the same
openings
again and again maybe less so less so
than some of the other players in the
tournament rajabov
especially with white he can surf with
both hands he can um
i mean he can surprise his opponent with
anything um the one thing i can
think we will expect is a solid opening
from rajabot and is this move a solid
opening yes this is
this is looking to be a very very solid
opening
i i expect him to fully continue with
his strategy
of just closing the life out of the
position and just
forcing duboff to play in a position
that he doesn't feel comfortable in
and uh yeah it's worked so well you know
he's won
he won the match yesterday 3-1 he's in
the lead now
he just has to continue doing what he
has to but he's been doing
and he wants to minimize the risk um
white not occupying the center
immediately with pawns
we call this opening the reti opening
as as white it's just very very flexible
you wait to see what black does
that's why daniel dubois he's having a
think here as black you need to choose
your setup
how are you going to develop your pieces
how are you going to get your king to
safety
he chooses to push a pawn on the left on
the left side he's just creating a
square for his bishop
for the black bishop to reign supreme
along the
longest possible diagonal there timor
raj above
so i mean he's kept that flexibility
open and he will have looked at this
position
thousands of times before now he pushes
his queen's pawn forward
um very solid stuff from white here very
classical traditional stuff
remember he definitely does not want to
take risk in this game he will take his
chances when they come
if he does win he's through to the final
but he knows
frustrating daniel dubov stifling him
stopping him from getting his type of
position that is the priority
yeah and we have seen kind of a little
bit of unusual move order in fact
um we don't often see this opening at
high
level where they neglect to develop
their dark squared bishop
and focus on developing the light square
bishop and i know that this
is actually a system that's very popular
with the old english grand masters
i know nigel short was a big fan of this
and also jonathan spielman
and it's inviting white to take the
center
and then once white has taken the center
they're like fine we're going to
attack yes and we do see um white does
have these two nice
pawns controlling lots of central
squares right now meanwhile some bishops
have been developed
um you mentioned at yavanka in the
english school of chess this is what we
play quite often
as black but it's only because we're too
lazy to study our openings
we don't want to learn anything we just
want to get our pieces out into sensible
positions
and then maybe out maneuver the opponent
a bit later in the middle game and
both players developing very naturally
now both kings you notice
very quick to castle very quick to dart
towards that right side
um to safety this game it will liven up
a bit later on it's all about the center
now whose pieces will be better placed
to control the center
and if we bring up the analysis board we
can see the key factor in this position
are maybe as well the bishops especially
after this last move look at black's
bishops
along the longest possible diagonals um
these bishops will create
this kind of like kind of sword effect
this arrow effect along these two
diagonals black is trying to open things
up that is why he doesn't mind
uh letting white occupy the center with
pawns because the black bishops
they will control squares long range
they will eye up the center from afar
this position is balanced personally i
quite like it for black but white is
extremely solid
yeah i actually quite like this position
for black as well
just because i've been on the receiving
end with the white pieces
i've just not known what to do because
once you know once you start developing
and you get the happy moves in you kind
of the question is then well what are
you going to do next and
any pawn advance in the center you know
it's going to get challenged
and again you are anticipating all these
counter strikes
so i do like this opening for black
yes and meanwhile black is trying to
strike in the center black finally
pushing upon to
put to gain some influence on those
central squares
to put some pressure on whites nice
pawns there in the middle
um white meanwhile two more red bull
very calm just pushing a queen up one
square
yeah this is very cagey stuff from both
sides so far
i expect to see white's rooks now they
are nicely connected they will start
heading towards the middle of the board
daniel dubov very solid and he's trying
to keep tension
notice no pawns have been traded that
means not too many open lines
this will be a long game and the longer
longer the game goes on the more he'll
fancy his chances
to at least confuse rajabov rajabov the
one thing he's done badly
actually maybe this time is his clock
handling his play on the board has been
phenomenal uh almost perfect but
on the clock he has struggled slightly
so that will be rajabov's idea to keep
tension as long as possible
teamwork of he he did actually stop
playing chess
um it's a few years ago now he just
retired
what made him come back do you think
yeah just love of the game maybe
um i know that personally if i don't
play for a few months i miss the feel of
those pieces
and uh maybe timor raj above taking that
break for a few years
um it did kind of reignite his hunger
and he's suddenly back at the top of
world champs he won this knockout uh
this world cup in 2019
that was kind of the this kind of boost
big boost for his career and it kind of
accelerated that comeback
i don't think he fully ever like ever
fully retired he still played
occasionally
but he didn't study as hard as the top
guys he didn't play in these big big
tournaments
he just seems fresher than the rest of
the guys yeah he certainly does he's
really like a breath of fresh air and
we're not the only ones who are admiring
the
roger boss play we have a tweet from
abhishek who says roger chess has been
playing some of the solid and creative
chess
looks unbeatable it's a shame he's not
one of the candidates exactly the type
of player who can challenge magnus
carlsen
and we have another tweet from aid kopi
he says more or less the same thing
danu dano dubois raj above shows again
why the end game is so complex by the
way
rajabov's calmness is in the face of
pressure should be studied
just incredible and we did criticize
that his clock handling but
having said that he has never panicked
he has never looked flustered on the
screen
and uh that is just amazing yeah and
yesterday in one of the games timor
rajabov he went down to one second on
the clock
he did that three times but he wasn't
flustered he still found fantastic moves
he actually found winning moves with one
second left on his clock
that is how calm he is that is how
focused he is and
definitely i'm going to try and learn
from that i think some of the other top
players in the very world uh
very top players in the world they can
learn from that as well and
meanwhile this position is it has
actually all been seen before
um i've played this on the black side
white using a bishop there
white's bishop has edged up towards that
um
that right corner and just trying to
trade off the defender of black's king
the black dark squared bishop um will be
traded off
but still a lot of tension left all the
pawns still on the board
all right rajabo he did pull out of the
candidates he had qualified
he decided to pull out because of the
covet uh virus
um we know the candidates it was
eventually
postponed it's gonna be played sometime
in 2021
and hasn't rajabo said something about
wanting or hoping to be taken back
in after that yes i mean but now it's a
situation it's so complicated who knows
what's going to happen i think they're
going to resume without him but uh
yep definitely he would have that
feeling of missing out
yeah it kind of kind of wasn't his fault
because ultimately roger buff was proved
right that the coronavirus was going to
be
very deadly and was going to be
contagious but uh
okay it is what it is and instead he's
here
playing some fantastic chess over the
new year and uh
it's so impressive yeah that's it's a
shame in
in a way i mean imagine the way he's
playing right now he would have been one
of the favorites to qualify to play
against magnus carson
for the world title and i think raj
above as well he still has a score to
settle because his last candidate's
tournament in 2013 in london
he really struggled he lost a couple of
times magnus carlsen he at the time i
think he was number four in the world
and
that was maybe when his descent started
that's when he kind of fell out of
loving uh with chess so
getting back into the candidates that
might have uh that might have just
kind of brought things full circle and
um yeah it's a real shame i would have
loved to see him play in that
i imagine if he actually would have
played the candidates qualified to play
against magnus and become
world champion after actually retiring
from chess
coming back and becoming world champion
the way he's playing well it looks like
he would be capable
yeah that gives hope to everyone at home
as well who doesn't really play full
time
if you love the game if you study in
kind of a really productive way then
yeah you can definitely get to the top
yeah that's one of the kind of secrets
about playing good chess and you just
have to love chess it just has to come
naturally to you
and you just have to want to do it all
the time just like you would art or
drawing
so yeah yes and meanwhile on the board
we did see those dark square bishops
leave the board there was a trade of
bishops white's rooks now
nicely in the center but we've seen a
similar scenario in previous games
all of white's piece is actually pretty
much perfectly placed it's hard to
improve them
and that is the problem for timor roger
that's why he's burnt
five minutes on the clock um as white
here
how do you improve white's position it
looks too perfect in a way
um white's pawns occupying the center
the rooks in the middle the queen nicely
placed the nice light
at the knight nicely placed as well
meanwhile daniel dubov
his moves are a bit easier his plan
should just
bring the black rooks towards the center
as well
daniel dubois he knows where his next
two or three moves are timor regional
spending a bit of time here trying to
come up with a plan
meanwhile i'm pretty sure this has all
been seen before right this is has all
been seen before this is we are
right in the depths of the main line
it's just not very common line
so therefore rajaboff is probably
unfamiliar with this position
again he's chosen a move that has been
played
and it's a very rare move and uh in fact
this is the move that nigel shaw himself
faced when
he played it and um white's last move
um it's just temporarily putting the
knight on the side of the board remember
we don't like to see those nights
nights are terrible often on the side of
the board especially if they're not
going to jump
to a better square a bit later so
white's knight temporarily
leaving itself there more importantly
he's opened up his own bishop the white
bishop now
staring at black's strong bishop in the
middle of the board he's just
angling for a trade again he's asking
for another trade another set of pieces
going to come off the board still a lot
of tension left
but maybe this is rajabov's strategy he
just wants to eliminate
all active pieces all of black's best
pieces
kill the fun out of this game kill the
life out of it and just
try and grind out that draw um edging
him closer to the final yeah it kind of
really reminds me of uh
swedish grandmaster ulf anderson this is
the kind of thing that he
absolutely excelled on he would take a
position like this with the exact same
pawn structure
he would swap off the pieces and then he
would just kind of go well you know i
have some extra space and he would
actually win
he would really just slowly push forward
and
yeah we can see the jedi of psychology
in action once again swap off the pieces
and uh see what devolve is going to do
with his lack of tension
yeah do both meanwhile i wouldn't say he
looks unhappy
but he definitely doesn't look as
focused as kind of energized as he did
in that quarter final against magnus
carlsen
um dubov yeah he just hasn't got the
type of positions that he likes
and i think the one uh kind of
interested viewer will be magnus carlsen
he will be taking tips
from timor rajabos match strategy he
knows now
that daniel dubov who has eliminated him
from this tournament
who has given him so much trouble in the
past maybe daniel dubois he does
struggle
for consistency in these types of
simplified positions
where he can't get to the opponent's
king um so maybe this is just very
instructive
play by team or rajabov and i know this
is for me
this is the type of psychology that i
enjoy watching i know for magnus it will
be something to learn from as well
no it's a different type of chess i mean
this one i find just as beautiful
as um as a like a big sacrificial attack
i just really like it when the two top
dogs kind of like out maneuver each
other you see psychology at play
you see issues like just time control
the personality of the player
because this is kind of you don't often
see this at the top level
this is something that's much more
common say in an open
big swiss player swiss open where you
have
thousands of players playing different
levels
and uh it takes a kind of a takes it
kind of all the way back
a new new approach yeah so meanwhile if
we
if we bring up the analysis board we can
see timor rajab he has spent a lot of
time on the glock but he's done
something
quite scary quite clever he's put his
queen ominously close to this black king
this black king will never feel safe now
over the next few moves and the white
knight i said it was terrible on the
side of the board potentially
this white knight might try and combine
with the white queen to create a
checkmating attack
meanwhile though the square that they're
pointing at they're both pointing at
this square it is
very well fortified this pawn is very
well protected
by its fellow at the moment black's king
position is safe
but he should not get uh he should not
allow
white's knight to be improved he should
not get nervous about the fact he's
kings in the corner it's very easy to
panic here
but i think timor rush above his attack
it's a bit of a semi bluff
um right now he just needs to be patient
and evict that queen a bit later on
yeah yeah it does look scary though i
have to say i actually lost to fabiano
caruana because he put his queen
on that square and he kind of criticized
my play afterwards he said you should
always chase that queen away why are you
letting me have such a
beautiful queen in the middle of your
camp and
i was like well there's lots of tactics
happening as well and he was like no no
no no focus on that queen
so i i do expect people to chase that
queen away so you think that's priority
number one
get rid of that queen yeah i i i think
so i mean it's just through super
unpleasant because you know
the problem with the queen like that is
you start to get uh ghosts
in your head you start like oh well you
know maybe if white rearranged his rook
in the night you know if there's a rick
there and then suddenly there's a knight
in another square
and everything is pointing towards that
pawn in front of the black king
um yeah then it's checkmate and before
you know it that's how the ghosts
operate you know
before you know it in your head white
has had all these moves
you've had none and uh you see if you go
onto full-on panic mode
yes and daniel dubois he's not one used
to
seeing ghosts and he actually just
ignores the white queen
he's just saying you do your worst you
try to do whatever you want i'm going to
ignore you i'm calling your bluff
and there he swings the black rook off
to the other side there you go
he's ghost number one coming so he's
retreated that night
to a different square and it has a plan
it has a kind of adventure it's gonna
jump to the square that i was
fearing and uh you can see it there
yes that's exactly where it's going to
be jumping to
so it can start looking at those two
pawns next to the black king
and that all i need now is one more
magical piece into the attack and it
will be like
wow fun times so you think white should
jump his knight forward
maybe eyeing up this pawn no no no just
keep it in reserve we don't want to
reveal the cars
just yet we just kind of we want the
idea to ferment a little bit
okay the key for black is that he at the
moment he does defend this pawn with his
knight he does
defend the other pawn with his king so
for now
it's okay for black but you're right
ivanka it does look ever so scary
um especially in these short time
formats you need a bit of time to
compose yourself and realize that you
are defending
yeah everything yeah it's actually very
important to kind of
be very calm and we see rajabov just be
exceptionally calm in this respect
but uh yeah definitely what dubois needs
to do is just
not anticipate and not panic about
certain things and it's very easy to do
especially when you don't have so much
time on the clock
yeah and uh one thing i learned from you
ivanka is that three is the magic number
white is only attacking with two pieces
the white queen and potentially the
white knight so
yeah personally i'm not too scared of
the attack
i'm a cynic i'm very skeptical of my
opponent's attacks and i think black has
done nothing
too wrong nothing to deserve being
attacked but it looks like you're right
your vancouver rajamov
is going for that checkmate um we talked
about him just simplifying things
getting pieces off the board play
maybe playing for a draw but no he
doesn't care he's going for checkmate he
wants to end the match
in this game he wants to end the match
now and uh
team uh team raj above that's a very
brave play
um and daniel dubov meanwhile retreating
his queen the black queen is actually
going to
move across two squares next move next
to the black king to try and
exchange off white's queen while it's
dominant very scary queen there
yes so so you can kind of see dubois is
reacting to this
he is somewhat afraid because like you
said oh
are we are we seeing a potential draw
offer in the air like he's moved his
knight forward and then retreating it
and it's kind of inviting
we know that daniel dubois loves to do
the same he will not i'm very surprised
by that in that move because you know
that night maneuvered itself to a great
square
i was expecting to back it up with some
pawns
some central pawns and just go for you
know having said
forward i want to go forward again i'm a
bit surprised by this uh dance
yeah i think maybe if timor rajab if he
was if he was in a must-win situation
uh remember he would probably be happy
with the draw here but if rajabov was in
a must-win situation he probably would
have gone straight for the black king
continued attacking but
retreating um it doesn't commit his
position white's still really flexible
mm-hmm um i think it's a sensible
decision to retreat
and yeah still he hasn't ruined anything
yeah
i just i just thought it was the time
you know you put your night in a great
square
and it was perfectly supporting a
central pawn
can just see this is my style i just
want to go forward all the time
that's where we differ for your anchor i
like to just stay curled up in a ball
just wait for my chance
to stay that's because you're a spider
david spider
yes all right the neil dubo he needs two
wins
uh in the three last games here to take
it to tie breaks and the maximum vaginal
gravity also needs
uh to win to take it to thai race and
i'm just keeping an eye on
the game between him and levonorone and
in the bottom here and it looks like
white is
playing quite well that makes him does
have an advantage in that game so we
could have some exciting tie breaks here
today
all right but uh daniel dubo will he
shouldn't be happy with the draw in this
game definitely not and ivanka mentioned
it white uh timor regive he was kind of
inviting a repetition of moves
um if the position repeats itself three
times that is a draw but daniel dubois
he said no
i'm going to try and play for the win
i'm going to try and keep the tension
and black's last move with his queen
he's eyeing up white's pawn there on the
same line that white pawn is undefended
it's one of the only undefended things
in white's camp
that's maybe it's not the most
aggressive move yes it does attack a
pawn
but it's just asking the opponent a
question how do you defend it
asking him to burn a bit of time yeah on
the clock trying to figure that out in
rajabov it did
he did spend a bit of time he's now six
minutes below on the clock
what do you think ivanka well i i
thought that dubois last move was very
intriguing because i thought it was a
bit provocative because a player of my
style
would be like you you want me to go
forward
with pleasure i would have said but uh
okay instead you see it's something very
non-committal from raj above really he's
not giving
that much ground he's really trying to
kill off the game
and uh he's just advancing his work
forward just to protect
that pawn in the center but uh yeah very
surprising for me i wouldn't have
expected i would be
quite frustrated by this kind of
solidity
and daniel dubov now he must be thinking
is the time right to try and strike to
launch an attack maybe on that left side
if we bring up the analysis board we can
see
um white's just defending that pawn with
his last move with that rook move and as
ivanka mentions
one very tempting option next move if
white gets time is to push forward
and attack this black queen gaining even
more space in the center so meanwhile i
think daniel dubois
this has to be the moment surely to push
to create some counter play to
actually create some winning chances at
least it might work it might not but
either way he needs to try
lots of tension here um this is where
black's rooks are these two lines
okay he doesn't do this these two lines
though i think black needs to open
these up for his rooks he needs to open
up some pawns there instead
in this position he just dropped his
queen forward eyeing up this white king
it's a sensible move but there is no
immediate threat he's still biding his
time
i actually like it because you know it
is really i think
dubois is finally adapting to the
situation
he cut he knows that actually rajab
wanted him to make that poor move
because
rajabov kept everything in the center so
fluid and so
tension and uh here he's like okay i'm
not gonna do that
i'm just gonna improve my queen to the
maximum square you're gonna have a hard
job chasing it out
and i still have that idea of do making
that pawn advance on the left
and what are you going to do next and
it's a clever kind of plan
especially because when we look at the
clock differences
well rajaboff is under six minutes
meanwhile dubois has well 12 minutes
just
over 11 minutes uh maybe he does sense
that that is his uh
best chance to keep the tension as long
as possible and wait till rajabov gets
to down
uh well gets down to two or three
minutes and then open things up and then
pounce
and then start to kind of just try and
confuse him
um yeah meanwhile rajabov we did mention
that's our only criticism
of him in this tournament is that he's
played slightly slower than most of his
rivals
and that might become a factor later on
five minutes now
for rajabov still a lot of tension all
the pawns left on the board
he needs to clarify that tension somehow
to make his position just easier to play
personally i've always loved these
positions with black partly because as
we mentioned english school of chess but
partly as well because
it's not clear what white's plan is what
should white be aiming for do you gain
more space in the center do you
try and trade the queens what do you
keep on the board what do you
take off the board it's so many
questions and that's why timor raj above
is spending so much time
he needs to speed up yeah so that's uh
so we heard it here david
really likes the position for black but
uh i'd like to put that question
actually to the viewers who
do you prefer to play do you think
dubois
is actually going to do it going to
strike back it's a very tense situation
right now
and we'd love for you to join in the
conversation and you can do this by
tweeting
us using the hashtag chesschamps
yes and um i mean i i prefer to be black
here just because it's easier to play
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
black has the advantage and we see that
on the evaluation bar it's roughly in
the middle surprising move there by
timor rajabov
but he was uncomfortable with that queen
just eyeing up his king
indirectly so he does step back with the
king an odd move
an odd square for the king um he did
just move his king remember
white only put his king up one square
just a couple of moves ago now he's
retreating it again that really shows
some
indecision on rajabov's part it shows
he's not fully sure
what his plan is either and um yeah
daniel dubois
six extra minutes he needs to come up
with a plan quickly he needs to keep
applying that pressure on the clock
as well as on the board what an odd move
though
i would never have in a million years of
moving my king like that
i would have been thinking about maybe
retreating the queen
but i really am not liking the trend of
uh rajabal's position you know i
i really didn't approve of just moving
the work slightly forward i felt that
this was the time to kind of
go forward and uh yeah okay we'll see
what happens next
yeah i'm not entirely sure what uh
dubois should be doing
to take advantage i mean i i would is it
is the time right now david to actually
make that pawn push or is this wait and
see strategy just
working a treat i think both the fine
and duboff he
goes for that wait and see strategy that
last move by black it actually doesn't
do too much but it's just
putting the onus back on white saying
okay it's your turn again
your clock is ticking you didn't come up
with a plan last move so
can you come up with a plan this time
and rajabov spending more time on the
clock going to go under four minutes
soon
um yeah i like the strategy from dubov i
think finally
he's playing those mind games back he
has been the one under pressure
he has been playing on rajabov's home
ground on his territory
now he's finally kind of embracing that
psychology and saying okay
now i'm going to put the pressure on you
i'm going to i'm going to play mind
games i'm going to wait
you're the one who has to do something
this time i'm not going to make it easy
for you
and well but we see the waiting
continuing
because uh now raja buffer just moved
his rook
one square up the board uh perhaps he's
perhaps now he's thinking i'm gonna get
rid of this
queen because it was a little bit
annoying in the side but um
as black i would be tempted okay the
waiting c continues it's like a cat and
mouse game
i was expecting okay now they're finally
gonna
push with the pawn on the left side but
nope it continues
the queen has now moved yeah those
queens are dancing around
um the black queen just retreating one
square but note how she's
now on the same line as the white king
that is always slightly uncomfortable
just that is why um timor rajabov he
does
shift his king back to the square it
came from away from the eye line of that
black queen this is very cagey both
sides
i think neither of them really know
exactly what their plan is they're just
kind of freestyling
just waiting and i must admit i would be
tempted just to put my queen
back there and say are you going to
retreat the king to f1 i'm sorry
and then i'm just gonna just open up
the problem with that is if you make a
quick move if you make white's move
obviously more radical he'll play it
immediately and gain 10 seconds on the
clock and
maybe you don't want him to gain time on
the clock yeah when we when you look at
the clock situation you can see
that uh dubois is just under nine and a
half minutes
meanwhile rajabov is three and a half
minutes down
yes um three and a half are we gonna see
if he has retreated the queen
okay so will the king take that step
back yeah so
we um if white retreats his king we will
see a repetition
of that position that'll be the second
time we've seen it
the game will not be declared drawn
unless we see it for a third time
um so still a bit of leeway there for
duboff to improve or to choose a
different move next time
meanwhile rajabov i'm surprised surely
okay he does repeat the move uh so this
is the second time we've seen this
position
now is the chance now is the time break
do something don't you you cannot afford
to kind of like
repeat in such an unusual way it might
be kind of quite funny and humorous but
i think now is the time the king is
really strangely placed
open yes so white's king it's not well
placed and if we bring up the analysis
board
ivanka says the word open and that means
pawn breaks pawns putting pressure
against other pawns
in order to open up lines um and i think
this move pushing the pawn on this side
look at this tension again just opening
things up here and the reason black
should open up the position is because
white's king is just a bit funny and
a bit weaker than its uh its opponent
the black queen dominant here in the
middle of the board
if black can open up the lines for these
two rooks then black will have a big
advantage
and meanwhile that will give an awkward
decision to timor rajabov if black
pushes this point i don't know what
white should do
it's very hard to keep the position
closed suddenly it's a whole different
ball game
suddenly it's very direct play after all
this slow maneuvering
rajabov with only three and a half
minutes he might not be able to adjust
to that new kind of
well exactly but uh you know rajabov
still has a lot of fans on twitter
we have a tweet from roland duke who
says rajiv is simply playing
consistently good that duboff just can't
beat him today
we'll move to the final against aronian
i don't know
i i have to i'm not sure i agree with
that comment because it seems like in
this game
dubois is finally get the measure
getting the measure of these mind tricks
yeah but has he left his late charge i
mean has he left it too late in the
match
um i mean he not only needs to win this
game remember but he also needs to win
one of the last two
at least and not be defeated yes stills
still this game in the bag and still two
more games to go
anything can happen it doesn't actually
matter you know what margin he wins as
long as he wins the match that's enough
okay and daniel dubois he continues to
play the waiting game
again it's this shadow boxing just
players sizing each other up
that's a very non-committal move by
black just shuffling the rook across
there
we do generally like to advocate this
doubling of rooks the two rooks lined up
together we love that
in general but maybe black should have
been a bit more direct
now white has closed down the center
like gaining space in the middle and now
we see those two black rooks they look a
bit silly
they should i mean now they're
completely blocked um daniel dubois may
be
just missing an opportunity to open
things up okay he finally goes for that
poor move that we've been
asking for over the last five or six
turns and
the problem is for the black rooks they
want to be on a different line they want
to be shifted one line across
um in order to be ready for the position
to open black's rooks
they look nice but they're just too
blocked at the moment and in the other
semi-final match between maximum vaginal
grav and levon aronian the second game
is finished it
ended in a draw and that means that
maximum vaginal graft still needs
a win in one of the two last games if le
von neronian wins the next game
then it is over and aronian will be in
the final
and he will face one of these two
probably right now looks like it's going
to be timor rajabov
and actually i see on the bar with this
last move yes he's getting an advantage
uh quite possibly and actually this is
very very sneaky play
by timor rajabov if we bring up the
analysis board we can see maybe there's
one factor
that we didn't take into account a few
moves ago and now it's actually the fact
that this black queen
is lacking escape squares it might
potentially get trapped
at the moment it only has one escape
square one safe square to run away to
that is to step back so timor rajabov
with this last move
uh pushing the pawn forward it's taking
away one square from the queen
maybe if he gets time uh for example if
black makes a move on the other side
if white gets time he might push this
pawn forward as well suddenly
taking away black's only safe square for
the queen and this queen
would be trapped in the middle of the
board such a rare scenario
a rare case to happen and white would
win that queen by bringing his rook
across
this is very sneaky stuff by team
rajabov maybe daryn dubov
you missed this idea yeah i think so too
this is
super dangerous look at that sneaky paw
move trapping the queen in the middle of
the board
that's so unusual but uh okay well
we are gonna see something in action
because now i'm
i i don't think he's seen it actually
i'm gonna call it i don't think he's
seen it i don't think he's even
considered the possibility
that his queen might get trapped because
now
we are fully expecting rajabov to
move his pawn on that square that david
illustrated and potentially trap the
queen
and there we see it the computer moves
just below the board there it does
suggest
pushing this pawn forward taking away
the remaining escape square for the
black queen and the black queen is
trapped
it just can't move next move next turn
white will just try and attack this
queen try to win the queen
um daniel dubov he blundered he missed
this move
he actually he's losing now because this
black queen
cannot run away but will rajabov be
brave will he find this move
uh pushing the pawn forward and trapping
the black queen so we are looking for
one move by timor on you above now
that one point yeah and actually just
look at the play i think it's just
dawned on dupoff
he is really not happy and uh you can
see
rajapov is now on pounce mode you know
because why else did he make that pawn
move
if he didn't have this in mind
and less than two minutes on the clock
and we are looking for this one porn
move by
timor rojabo and if he makes it he's
simply winning this game
he should be i mean it's still not over
yet the black queen isn't
immediately attacked so he will have one
okay
it's on the board david it's on the
board okay dybov is
in trouble and he's found the best
response to
to push the pawn and give his queen an
escape square
but uh okay you know this is a seriously
bad position now
yeah that last move it's a move that
daniel dubois did not want to play
it's the type of move you have to make
in desperation but
you want that pawn further back now uh
white has
many uh tempting options
um timor rajab he can go for a long
strategic advantage
okay he plays a special move we've
mentioned in the past on passant
when a black pawn moves two squares
forward on its first turn
it can be captured as if it just moves
one square and white does
trade the pawn in the center it does
look like white is going to go a pawn up
and um it's not just any pawn the
black's position is starting to crumble
okay black takes that pawn back with his
queen um
okay timor rajabov has again many
tempting options
daniel dubov his queen has survived so
he did
not lose immediately but white has a big
big advantage now
um white for example i would be thinking
of improving that rook at the bottom
there just shuffling
he's played something else david he has
moved the queen and is now attacking
that backward pawn in the center it's
backward it cannot move forward
and just look at those all those pieces
on that diagonal those
two black ropes the porn and the white
queen
i've never seen a pattern like that have
you very rarely
and um ivanka mentions this pattern this
queen has retreated
on its last turn but more importantly
it's eyeing up black's pieces along this
diagonal black has many
undefended pieces on this diagonal the
first target though
is this pawn look white is ganging up
using teamwork ganging up against this
pawn it's only defended once
and even if black defends it white's
other rook will be ready to join the
action imagine three pieces ganging up
against this poor pawn
it will be lost quite likely um white
will go upon up and he will be odds on
to win this game
uh daniel dubois he's just missed these
last few moves he's under pressure
and look at his face he does not look
happy right now yeah he could be
out in uh just two games if rajabrov
wins this game and is looking very
promising that is it
he is through to the final because oh
dear me what what great chess from
rajabo yeah
he's just been supreme supreme the only
thing that can stop him
we've said this before and he's never
stopped him in the past but the only
thing that could stop him
is the clock white now only got one
minute left timor rajabov he does have
this dominating position
especially because daniel dubois has had
to retreat tonight
um the black knight guarding that pawn
that we highlighted
but the black knight is terrible on the
edge of the board it had to
put itself on a far worst square just to
survive
uh just to make sure that the black of
the the rest of black's position didn't
crumble
and that black is also forced to retreat
the queen
all of black's pieces are retreating now
they are heading backwards
there's just nothing else for them to do
yeah they think white is in complete
control
all he needs to do is improve the rest
of his pieces look at that that night is
now coming in
here comes johnny
but is this uh well not a very great
move by timor
i think it's good enough and then we see
the bart does correct itself the
computer just needed a while to
understand
the depth of that move the strength of
that move and white's knight
i mean it's that common wisdom that
ivanka has mentioned on many occasions
if you go backwards i'll go forwards and
black has had to retreat his own knight
his own queen now white jumping forward
with his knight uh the only piece that
needs to join the action now is white's
remaining rook at the bottom there
once that rook joins the action as well
all of white's pieces
will be heading towards the attack
together meanwhile black's rooks
are not looking impressive black's
knight is terrible and the queen is also
far more passive than she was yes i mean
the only thing
that is in black's favor and this is
something that hatams
on twitter has pointed out is that raja
has not so much time
on the clock and that makes things not
clear
yes and um we have mentioned timor raj
above
even when he goes down to one second he
is capable of these great moves
so um judging by his track record in
this tournament at least
he still got this under control but
daniel dubov
he has to play on that time factor he
has to somehow make rajabov nervous
somehow just throw him off that kind of
jedi-like
um zen that rajabov has found even in
these time scrambles even when low on
the clock
yes so david you did a lecture on
coaches all about
um surviving bad positions and even
turning them around what kind of
approach would you advocate now for
dubois
yeah i would not have advocated that
last move dubov he's opening things up
in the middle he's
trying to just go for the fact that
rajabov is low on time and that he won't
have enough
uh he won't have enough time to think um
and
maybe he might panic due to this very
direct approach personally i
prefer that kind of curl up in the ball
in the ball approach
just survive as long as possible and the
longer you survive in a bad position the
more nervous your opponent will get
daniel dubov he's saying to rajapov okay
i'm going to push forward
maybe you can punish me immediately um
but
maybe not and there we see a trade of
pawns in the middle raj above not
panicking
but down to 30 seconds now and black is
actually black was threatening checkmate
in one move on that last turn black's
queen
was going to try and bring itself down
to that bottom right corner to checkmate
the white king that's why white's king
has taken the time out to step across
covering all the weak squares
covering any entry squares for the black
queen yeah
we kind of still have to mention that
the advantage that white has
isn't material you know it's not he's
not a pawn up it's not anything like
that
it's just that he has better pieces and
uh definitely
he has to do something with this
momentum so things could
easily shift if he makes a few you know
inaccurate moves maybe even a bad move
and that that could immediately see a
turnaround
yeah so we it's definitely not game over
especially with raj above
now under 20 seconds on the clock um
it's still not over
we could see a turnaround but raj above
if he's calm if he's
stays collected then there are chances
i don't like it he keeps pushing himself
in this pressure situation
i think he's determined to or increase
our blood pressure simultaneously
it's just too nerve-wracking okay so raj
above improving his night and he set up
a very nasty trick
actually yeah so raj above um putting a
knight in the middle of the board these
octo knights controlling eight squares
they're so fantastic when they're in the
middle that white knight also dominates
the black knight the black knight cannot
move
and um okay just while rajabov thinks uh
no sorry just while dubov
thinks we will maybe bring up the board
to highlight the key threat in this
position
there's maybe two threats and it's all
to do with knight forks if black is
careless and just moves upon
on the other side of the board white
will pounce he will capture this rook
with his queen he will sacrifice his
queen temporarily
luring the black knight away the black
knight was covering this square and then
now suddenly
white can jump in with his knight with a
fork attacking
well giving check to the king and
attacking the queen as well white will
win material
if this happens so a deadly threat and
it's all to do with this square that the
knight
uh finds itself on now can daniel dubois
cover this square he has to prevent this
threat somehow yeah he definitely does
this is a dirty little trick that one
because the instinct is maybe to cover
another squad oh
okay so he has played a very unexpected
move
this is another blunder um it does look
like white
possibly has a few uh he can grab the
pawn i think he can get greedy and just
grab he's seven seconds and he's done it
he's described that pawn because the
queen
cannot capture that rook because then
the knight will move
with a check and black will lose the
queen and
that is why dubois just throws in some
checks
and uh now he is forced to move the king
yeah so um we should ignore the bar
there um it just it will re-correct
itself
there we go white's king under attack he
moves that king
out of check and black now threatening
checkmate he's going on the attack
i think we're going to see the king run
look at that he's like whoa what's
happening well he's going down to two
one second oh yeah
and the white king is running for the
hills white's king is going on an
adventure
it was getting attacked from behind the
white king could find itself
even close to the black king it could
even be hunter i would
love to see that if the king runs all
the way up
right into the heart of the black
position yeah i would be like get going
forrest go
well we have to remember if team rajaba
wins this game then it is all over he
will be in the final
so daniel dubo he needs to find a way to
get this to a draw
or preferably to a win yes and um just
while dubois thinks i think he's
he's going to spend a lot of his
remaining time in this position it's the
critical moment
if we bring up the analysis board we can
see why white made this move he just
brought his king up one square because
black was threatening to come and
checkmate
and trap this white king it had to step
up the board and that king is going on a
journey
that white king is seeking safety up the
board um he's going to try and
continue running he's going to try and
seek refuge
deep in in enemy territory deep in
black's camp
the white king it may or may not be safe
there who knows
but this is what rajabov is aiming for
i'm sorry this is what makes chess
absolutely fun you know
you never see a king run like that that
is just one rare breed
so okay so that's why dubois
has stopped that king run but uh yes
yeah daniel dubois he's trying to cut
across white's plans there
timor rajab sidesteps with his rook look
at that rook
and the white queen they're lined up now
against one of black's pawns that black
one is only defended by a king
um now white is the one starting to
threaten checkmate both sides going for
the opponent's king
um i'm just loving the courage behind
rajabal's moves imagine he went down to
two seconds there and he found this
amazing idea of
using his white king to kind of zigzag
up the board um it does look like white
is still in charge the white king
safe for now at least but anything could
happen no there
this king this white king is absolutely
bold and brave and as safe as the houses
and okay well here you go here is the
mix-up he has
really taken he's really trying to throw
some magic into the air and see what's
happened but i assume
it's too much i think yeah so daniel
dubois he's he's in a desperate
situation he's trying
he's throwing everything at the opponent
but timor rajab look at that white king
hiding out up the board in the corner
there um timor roger
he's completely winning with white the
one saving grace for daniel dubovov is
he did manage to checkmate
magnus carlsen twice when magnus castle
ran away with his king so although
white is winning there's always going to
be hope as long as that's just look at
how many pieces they are protecting that
white king you know white has a queen a
rook and knight all
prepared to come to its its assistance
and uh
frankly there's no one getting out there
getting out that king
and okay so okay we have a threat i can
see a very sneaky threat but rajabov
very calm he just just defends
yeah he has been seeing ahead he's been
predicting
daniel dubov's attacking uh choices he's
attacking tries over the last few turns
the speed with which retroboth blocked
off black's rook there
um remember as well if we do a quick
count in the position white is two pawns
ahead
that is why white is trying to exchange
pieces also
trades especially of rooks especially if
queens they make your king
safer when you have the weaker king
trading pieces
it's very sensible and daniel dubois
there's just no way to get to that white
king that white king
has built a little palace around for
itself um that white king
super safe and it does look like daniel
dubov is
lost his body language as well shows
that he's just
coming to terms with the fact that this
will be his last game in the in the uh
air things masters um daniel dubois
trying to bring his rook up but
you look at the bar look at what the
computer says plus 100 for white
that means that the computer sees a
force checkmate a forced win now for
white
um and timor rajabal he goes for it the
black king is now the target white's
rook
zooming up to the top of the board
eyeing up the black king across that top
rank
um the game is pretty much over daniel
dubov
can he find a way to survive any longer
yeah it's looking unlikely and i'm just
super impressed by rajabov there and
chess bravo sums it up for me
rajabov must have ice in his veins so
cool
and calm under extreme time pressure i
have never seen the light before
and uh i love her daniel dubov has
resigned
it is all over not only this game the
semifinal match between these two
it's over don't you do well he's out
timor rajavo is heading to the air
things masters final
wow i have to say i'm a little bit
surprised i didn't think that before the
tournament started but
wow how impressive is his play and it's
just brilliant i it's it's masterpiece
in the making
i didn't love this game you know i
didn't expect it all these
very unusual maneuvers that he made
the kind of wait and see game and then
suddenly he pounced
and that's it uh duboff was helpless and
above well we see he's uh disappointed
but
uh not much to read out of teamwork oh
it's not easy to see if he's
probably inside david he must be so
excited
yeah it's so well deserved in he's
definitely hiding it right now he still
wants to maintain this jedi persona that
we we've come uh become so accustomed to
um but yeah he deserves it he'll be
confident in the final if he can
get past duboff who took down the world
champion he can maybe get past anyone
wow team urojabu he is ready for the air
things masters final it is a major
in the champions chester and team
rajabov he
is going to play the final now who will
he face he's gonna face the winner
in the semi-final match between
maximilian vacherdegrov and levon ronian
they just
started game three and
we know that maximizer he needs a win
in either of the two last games is this
the game to do it for him
it should be the game to do it but it's
not looking good we
criticized his opening choice in the
first game today
uh maxine vazquez maybe playing on his
opponent's terms allowing a queen trade
not going for the most ambitious
aggressive approaches black and
here we see the queens have already been
traded as well after only 11 moves
actually in all three of their games
today the queens have left the board
very early on and live on aronian taking
those draws
to edge him closer to the final and does
look that like that is likely
as well in this one um i've had these
types of positions
so many times in my career as black and
it's very hard to win against the best
players in the world
but with that last move by maxim the
black pawn moving up well the bar did go
over to to the white side was it a bad
move or is it
mexican showing that he he he's taking
risks now to to get that win yeah i
think a bit of both
uh maxime he's got his head in his hands
already he knows that that
was not a good move um if we bring up
the analysis board we can see
why that might not be such a good move
strategically
black just pushing forward this pawn
here
he's stopping the advance of white's
pawn temporarily but more importantly
look at this black bishop now blocked in
by it's so important this bishop
does not want to be locked in behind
some pawns i think
maybe that move is just too slow um
maximum growth he wants to develop his
other bishop
he wants to bring it out and make and
give a check but
he's just forgotten about the activity
of this piece and
white with an advantage already at this
early stage
why also with this very very nice strong
pawn center in the middle
it does look like levon aroni he's got
the dream scenario he can play for a win
without taking too much risk
we do see all the way in top of the
screen we see
um the points that they have gotten
today it's one
one after two draws but we also see the
score in yellow there
from yesterday levon aronian won the
first semi-final match he is up by one
point
maxim vagiela grav needs to win the
second match to take it to thai breaks
and is this a good or bad move by levon
aronian
it's a decent move maybe there was
better but white just
improves his rook brings that rook
across to an open line
um that white rook looking very nice now
down at one of those pawns tying up the
black bishop
black bishop we mentioned that was stuck
the light squared bishop
cannot move because now it's tied down
to the pawn that white's rook is eyeing
up
across the line a sensible move i live
on ironian and
the good thing for him is there's a lot
of margin for error in this type of
position even if things go really wrong
for white
you'll have great chances to guide this
one to a drawer yeah
now it's uh i once again you see that
kind of
strategy in place by lavonna rhony and
he takes the center
he's very calm and collected about it
he's just improving his pieces
developing
and he just leaves all the
decision-making to magazine rasheela
graf
and yeah i i just really
love the way that aronian's been playing
and i think it's just
fantastic you know it's just been
working so well against maxine basha de
graf and
that's why maxim has moved his born he
wants to get ready to challenge in the
center
and uh yeah
it's a very very interesting yeah we
have seen levon
ivanka spend um well maybe not his time
too wisely even if it's been all right
on the chessboard
um they have played quite fast here in
the opening actually
they have paid very fast i mean this is
something that we've criticized maxine
bachelor graph so many times that he's
been
taking such critical decisions very very
quickly
you know there's no possible thought i'm
i've been quite critical
about his opening choice you know the
thing is though he has been equalizing
as black but i feel
he has to put levon aronian under
pressure
and uh levon there advancing the pawn on
the right
this is a really great move because it's
not it doesn't really have any
aggressive intentions it's just going to
clamp down on the space
so he wants to secure every single piece
that he has
and uh now you're playing very fast here
super quickly and he's put the king in
check and this is just done just to
dislodge the king just to make it
slightly awkward
but this is like a little victory and
now we're probably expecting
lavon ironian to kind of focus on
development i expect the
light squared bishop to develop and then
connect the rooks and the game will just
develop a very
natural flow um we know lavon aronian
obviously knows that with a win here it
will be all over he will be in the final
can we sort of tell
by his play here if if he is going hard
for that win or if he's just
happy to play a draw and play a fourth
game i think he's happy to do whatever
is needed you know
this is one of the things that is so
essential in
a chess player's mindset you don't you
mustn't
impose what you want on the position
because if you impose what you want
then you'll take sharper decisions
you'll take risks or maybe you'll go
solid when you should actually be
playing aggressively and i've had the
best results of my life
actually when i've just been focusing on
the breath and just focusing on what
needed to be done
and here i think levon is so calm
he's super focused he would just be
looking at the position getting
absorbed into the game and making his
decisions based on that
it's totally a mistake to get nervous
and
just think i've got to win i've got to
do this you've just gotta first of all
for maxine vashilograph his task is
basically just to equalize
and once he's done that he must
formulate a plan
and then only then can he think even
about
winning or perhaps playing for an
advantage okay so but breathing
so that's a tactic you actually use yeah
i i yeah i focus on the breath and this
is just something that i find very
helpful especially
when i'm very very stressed there's just
something just to distract me from my
own emotion because
the brain is a funny thing it tends to
have its own dialogue with
dialogue with itself and i've noticed
the top players are very very confident
but for a much more mainstream players
the brain is always going oh you messed
up again
why am i not surprised and in order to
shut that voice out
or um then you just kind of think focus
on the breath and
i also saw an interview with vichy anand
where someone had an indian player yeah
and focus on that as well
and the one thing that really impressed
me about it is that someone asked him
the question
well what happens when you get that tune
stuck
in your head there's nothing worse when
you're playing and you've got some silly
little jingle in your hand in your mind
and you just can't shake it
and he said at first he was used to get
irritated and he realized that the brain
is such a wonderful thing that you know
it's actually a very small part of your
brain that is obsessed with this jingle
and the rest of the brain can actually
focus on the game
and i find just also deep breathing
breathing
breathe out just to be that kind of
thing just to bring me back
reset and focus i even have mantras i
even tell myself
really calm confident yeah i would love
to okay so you said that your superpower
you would love to
be able to read minds yes i'm actually i
would love to read your mind you might
go with your station
it sounds it's a bit chaotic and you're
talking to your pieces and you're
listening to a jingle and talking to
yourself
i think that would be that would be a
good reality show
your wanker's thoughts minute by minute
during your chess game
it's a bit nuts actually but yeah but on
that subject of uh
superpowers yeah i definitely want to
hear everyone's
desires for their superpower what is it
that you want to do and uh
if you want to get involved if you want
to enter the quiz then please
use the hashtag chesschamps the more
creative the better
we don't want to just hear i want to
rule the world well that is quite a nice
oh actually it does control the world
but the winner the lucky winner will win
one of these air
things devices which is which monitors
the quality
of the air in your room and i have to
say i'm becoming
more and more obsessed with this device
i know i mean i just love looking i know
that maxine bachelor graph has
perfect air quality he does he's the
player that we've seen
with the best air quality constantly
okay and now
after a long think david finally maxim
thinking he makes a move and the bar
shifts over to the white side again
yes and that might be because he's put
his knight on the side of the board
knights on the rim
are dim as we always say and yes that
black knight did kick back
um a white bishop but um i think those
deep breaths that maximum vascular graft
was taking
maybe they weren't quite um to the right
effect and we do see his air quality
there
it is slightly more humid than ideal um
for maximum vacuum versions of but the
rest is perfect perfect temperature
perfect
carbon dioxide levels and um yeah i
think maximum russian graph he needs
to hope that that air quality becomes a
factor because
um yeah levon aronian he's got this one
under control and then the white king
steps forward
connecting the white rooks most
importantly
um those white rooks now perfectly
placed pretty much
um the other white rook in the bottom
right corner it's going to
swing across um up to across to an open
line
black pieces they just don't look very
well coordinated the black knight on the
edge of the board
the black bishops aren't very active
they don't they aren't on very long
diagonals right now white controls the
center of the board
everything's against black in this
position
um he's not lost black very very solid
uh
doesn't have too many weaknesses but in
a must-win situation
uh remember maximizing off he needs to
win either this game or the next one
and not lose in the meantime um in that
type of situation
it's just the wrong the wrong match
right yeah
so have you ever been in a must-win
situation david many times
have you done do you 50 50 i think
50 50. sometimes you're able to do it
the adrenaline carries you through
sometimes you get that type of position
imagine sometimes you're in a must-win
situation and your opponent also is
um and that leads to the perfect
scenario where you both throw everything
at each other but
i think the the kind of the most
heartbreaking must win situation in my
career
came last year well in 2019 so not last
year anymore but um
towards the end of 2019 in the isle of
man um i just
i needed to win in the last game to
qualify for the candidates tournament um
which would find the winner again
uh which would find the challenger for
magnus carson and
i just had that prize in my mind i just
thought oh my god this is the moment i'm
gonna
get to the world championship and
conquer the world superman
but unfortunately that much must-win
situation it just went to my head and i
didn't sleep the whole night
um i i just kept waking up dreaming
about the game and
i couldn't focus and then my opponent
tried to make a draw against me and i
took a big risk which backfired
so yeah difficult these match these must
win situations and these matches in
general these head-to-heads these
one-on-ones but
um yeah i mean these players they've
been there before i think just maxine
vacherigrav
somehow maybe he just needed a coach to
advise him against this type of position
against levon aronian
um it just doesn't suit him it just
hasn't been going well so far
levon aronian is deep in his comfort
zone he does not look flustered
yeah i mean this is this is the thing
with this type of match is because
you know you are going to get knocked
out someone has to win so therefore you
have to adapt your style because
yes you can you know one of the things
with the black position is probably
probably pretty solid it's probably even
equal
and in terms of advantage white can't
really claim too much but
the problem is maxim needs to win he
needs to psych out lavon ironian and
he's kind of not doing that
um yeah and in fact uh we have a tweet
from raphael baptista who says
maxime is using pyjamas because he knows
that in the world of dreams it's easier
to eat
a little bit harsh all right well
actually as levonaronian is now thinking
we are
joined by timor java the winner of the
other
semi-final match team or congratulations
on going to the final
yeah thank you so much thank you uh yeah
i was just happy to be alive today after
the celebrations but that's fine
i tried to keep it as cool as possible
yeah so you were a little bit tired even
if you played
so solidly winning two games here well i
mean let's
uh let's be fair it's the aggressive
style of duboff
certainly that that was the reason of
these two wins because the last game
let's say
i was certainly trying to uh kind of
keep control and make a draw
and you know somehow i mean the draw is
is a good result in this situation
uh we're proceeding and then he will
have less games and uh
less chances to win so he will have to
win uh like two games after out of two
was it
yeah in case of draw yeah so that's uh
well that's the reason i was just kind
of uh standing on place wherever it's
called and
was trying to make a draw but uh yeah he
was going kind of aggressive
but he missed probably d5 and stuff and
the queen is then kind of trapped on e4
and it's problematic and also in the
first game i was not expecting him to
play like this in the very first game
because uh usually i've used like for
the guys like magnus
who will just play some kind of calm
chess and uh
put a lot of pressure till the very end
like for 100 moves and stuff
and um he just started with this g4
stuff
and even though it was very very
exciting game i think and at some point
he
he had uh great possibilities as well
but yeah
and i have to say timor we've been so
impressed
obviously with your play here the neil
dubo has been very solid so far
in the tournament and it seemed you just
had the perfect tactics
against his playing style what was your
tactics
um sorry kai i i just want to ask what
do you mean by
duba was solid i mean what kind of thing
is it because i mean he sacrificed like
uh half of his pieces in every game
that's true
which uh which um i mean which kind of
thing is playing style though
yeah because it made me happy because
i'm kind of like um like this
counter play guy i'm playing for for the
counter play most of the time so
kind of happy when people are playing
like this against me usually
um i don't like the style of like of
magnus of course and
when he presses just for for a very long
time and for many many hours
like simple positions and games and all
that stuff uh certainly i'm not bad
there i'm okay
but uh as all the top players but having
like uh
more fun when when people are playing
like this you know but um
yeah i think he wasn't solid to be
honest i mean he was really pressing
against
magnus as well and he was over pushing
and i think in some games carlson had
a lot of possibilities so i was trying
to cool him down as much as i can
i was playing all the boring positions
so that he will sacrifice something
maybe in the end game or something
but uh yeah and uh this way it worked
but
yeah this was kind of a kind of strategy
i had for the match to play as boring
as boring as possible but uh you can
thank dubo for for creating
a lot of interesting games and making me
you know
kind of show my best there so i just
have to ask we saw you
so many times running down your clock
two seconds left
how on earth did you keep so calm
um i'm not calm but you know my kind of
celebrations is not the kind of
celebrations of i don't know jan
or uh magnus or an or duboff let's say
i would never raise hands after winning
even a huge event let's say
the the world cup when i won it i just
uh
like calmly stood up and just uh yeah i
was congratulated by the by the fans and
so on and the arbiters and everyone
and the opponent of course but uh this
is not the way uh
i like to celebrate but inside it's like
i have a lot of emotions but outside
i'm trying to be as cool as possible and
not show it to anyone
yeah so um during the games of course i
mean with seconds on the clock certainly
uh i'm very close to heart attacks but
uh
yeah but still still still alive so it's
fine
and um no it's of course it's a
seemingly uh seemingly calm
calm you know maybe it seems that i'm
calm there but certainly not i mean it's
it's very stressful
but um i mean in my style and grisha
style we had all these problems with
time and uh in such complicated games
that
they created it was really hard to uh
not get into the
statement i cannot call it because it's
a 15 minutes game it's immediately the
same note
but i mean it's it's very hard of course
but
on the contrary i mean there is a huge
level of concentration like i'm very
focused and
uh can make a lot of mistakes but as
well you know
it's not about um it's not that i go
there by purpose you know it's just
i'm calculating stuff and then i see the
time is there and i have to do something
but
still i managed but many times i didn't
manage as well in my life
so yeah that's uh that's kind of tricky
and timo we're currently watching the
other semi-final
between aronia and vasily grav do you
have a preference who you'll face in the
final what are your scores like against
these guys
yeah i mean i have a pretty okay score
against boss i think maybe equal against
levon but it's otb and it's very
different and for the rabbits i don't
remember the rabbits and bleeds what is
the scores
i mean what are the scores against them
but certainly lebron is showing a very
high class this
uh these days i mean he's playing a
great chess there like
uh uh like in good old times when he was
playing this kind of uh
you know calm slow chess and not making
many mistakes very very simple chess and
so on
and um yeah i think he has better
chances certainly
uh for for winning especially that he's
leading so it's not hard
hard to say that hard to guess but uh
yeah he's showing a
better chance for now so i guess he will
qualify so finally
timor um we are just starting the new
year 2021 what does it mean to you
to be playing the final in one of these
big tournaments
yeah i mean it's a good year certainly i
mean for many days
i mean it seems to be a good year
because 2020 was
so so for many so um i'm actually not
sure that it will be better than 2020
somehow but
uh the first day is a bit better because
uh
last time i celebrated more than this
one because i had to play some i mean i
had to play this
semi-finals but uh yeah at least the
first day is better
than uh you know than the previous year
so i hope i have
you know good hopes and certainly hope
that otb chess returns back
even though now we're happily playing
online but still i hope for the otb to
come back
this is uh the biggest dream all right
teamwork good luck in the finals
starting tomorrow thank you for joining
us
thank you so much thank you and also
thanks to uh magnus carlson who just uh
you know lost in the quarterfinals
celebrated calmly with
all of his family and we're we're
working hard
fantastic team we'll see you tomorrow
yeah thank you see you bye-bye
all right well he is ready for the final
he will face uh one of these two guys
and
it seems it's dramatic david yes a lot
of action in this game and it's not been
going in
in the favor of maximum vascular we said
he has such a difficult position
and he is actually losing this game um
levon aronian look at that white rook
deep in the heart of
uh black's camp it has also snatched off
a pawn so white
is currently a pawn ahead and it's not
just any pawn it's the central pawn and
with that last move level neronia
brought his bishop up
eyeing up black's pawn there in the
middle x-ray vision again
against the black king the black king
had to sidestep and now levon he's
moving in for the kill
pushing a pawn in the center there all
of white's pieces are perfectly placed
perfectly active
black's rook is blocked black's light
squared bishop is also
very poorly placed and he's pulling down
just everything
going against fashion fasciolograph in
this game and we know that what that
means if levonoronia wins this game then
it is over
he will be in the finals maximum
vacciela grab he
he simply needs to find a way to to get
this back to a draw i guess
yeah it's not looking it's not looking
likely um maybe the only way black can
hope to draw this game is to somehow
miraculously trade the rooks off uh
trade off white's best piece that active
rook
but that's looking like a pipe dream
right now um
if the rooks disappeared maybe he could
use one of his bishops to trade off for
the white knight
we might see just not enough pieces left
for levon aronian to give checkmate but
look at that white knight now javanco
loves those types of pieces those octo
knights in the middle of the board
anchored as well by a white pawn that
knight is on an outpost it can't get
kicked away
by any enemy pawns look at black's
bishop that retreating
so ugly um yeah looking bad
it is looking bad and the moves are so
natural as well for lavon
just has to keep advancing his uh his
pieces
and just just watch out for that one
pawn that is being attacked in the
center
but i agree with you david look at that
night and just look at how instructive
his last
his last moves were like advancing the
pawn getting that square for the night
and uh yeah just devastating
for maxine bachelor yes and um
while everyone around thinks maybe we
can bring up the analysis board to show
just what he has to be careful of um he
just has to be careful of this one pawn
in the middle here it's not protected
black's rook suddenly attacking it
there's a few ways to deal with this but
if this pawn drops suddenly the black
rook and the black bishops might have
more life they'll have more diagonals so
um among the ways to defend this pawn
would be to just step forward
with the king there's other options as
well white
later on we'll try and grab a pawn along
this line okay he does step forward
with the white king this white king now
perfectly placed as well all of white's
pieces
are just harmonized together all
controlling such important squares and
in the end it will come down to the
strength of this white knight
all right it's looking dangerous for
maximum vagina again he spent
a little time here it's got 10 minutes
left on the clock
just not taking the time he should i
guess he's rushing
he's made that mistake so many times
he's playing too quickly um this rhythm
in rapid chess is so important you need
to be in a good rhythm you need to make
moves
um quickly and confidently but at the
same time you need to pause at the
critical moments at the key moments
every game has at least two or three key
moments when their trades happening when
there's
tricks traps when there's deep strategic
plans need to be made and maximum
version of
he's just not sensing those moments
that's why he's going to
down to defeat in the semi-final yes
yeah i agree with you there david just
look how easily
it just seems like it was like lavon was
following some kind of formula
just uh get the center incr increase
your pressure develop the pieces
winning position yeah and that's that's
what the top players do
when they're in form like levan aronian
is right now they make things look
simple they don't allow their opponent
any kind of
tricks or traps can any counter play any
hope
in the position um actually i think
seymour rajabov in the other semi-final
level ronin here they've just played the
opponent
perfectly they knew exactly what their
opponents wanted and they stopped them
from getting their types of game
um maximum vacheroth he's leaning back
he does look a bit despondent here
he's trying to keep his dark squared
bishop active black star squad bishop
there but now white's knight heads into
the position
again from a different angle this time
trying to creep in
black's pawn at the corner attacking the
white knight i do think levon aronian he
has enough time here
despite the clock situation four minutes
should be enough
um at the very least not lose but he
should be winning this game with a bit
of accuracy
yes and funnily enough though the best
move in the position i think is
for the night to go to the edge of the
board and give a check
wow that's not not a human move
at all um i think most humans will be
looking at getting
greedy and capturing something yeah so
white's knight and bishop are lined up
against the same pawn black's pawn in
the middle of the board there
white tonight could capture it um it's
probably not the best move it does
relieve some of the pressure on black's
position
ivanka as mentioned okay well there you
go
so this is why these are super ground
masters because that knight
has moved to the edge of the board and
in fact he's going to
be trapped he's 11 aronian
remember he's winning the semi-final
already he won
yesterday's match up and uh he's taking
a bit of risk here he's offered to trap
his own knight
i would never dream of that move but
that's why these guys
are so good they separate themselves at
the top of the chess world
white's knight can actually retreat now
black decided
not to try and go for that knight
immediately black's king stepping
towards the center
maxine vachelagrav though it shows he's
just
something's wrong this tournament i mean
this semi-final at least he's just not
taking time to think i would have i
thought that was a key decision just
there
um he's put his king maybe it's on the
best square but
there was choice there were four
possible moves and he played the move
instantly
um i'm shocked by maximum degrees time
consumption
um yeah just not allocated it correctly
in this game meanwhile at 11 aronian
he's banging for him he's finding these
moves that are so difficult to see
that's so counterintuitive he's finding
those moves when they're needed but he's
also just
playing nice sensible chess when that is
needed as well
yes and i'm fully expecting perhaps uh
lavon aronian just to advance with his
king
and just to kind of make an inroad into
the position because white
black is actually completely tied down
okay
he is going for something else he has
seen a pawn and he's gonna go
and grab that pawn yeah so if we bring
up the analysis board we can see
what white aim it what what is aiming to
do here with this bishop retreat the
bishop stepping back but the bishop has
a better target in mind the bishop wants
to
capture this undefended pawn it would
also give check to the black king
if he does this the problem for black is
if he defends this pawn with his king
then we will see the force of this
strong white rook across this line
we might see the white bishop step
forward this black bishop is pinned it
cannot move
because then the rook would attack the
black king and this would be terminal
for black this would pretty much
end the game um black his bishop would
likely be doomed the only way to save it
is to give up
uh even more material and see even more
trades so maxine bashadagrav
after this bishop retreat attacking this
pawn he's in a pretty much
hopeless position here levonoronian well
he doesn't have too much time on the
clock is it
sort of easy or hard to find the moves
he needs to find here
it's i don't think it's that hard it's
maybe not easy and there's still some
life left
black still has these two bishops and
two bishops together
they can create some kind of threats
they can dominate a lot of the board
but um with maximum vascular last move
he's just giving up another pawn
black's about to go two pawns down just
to get rid of a white strong rook
um i think levon he'll just grab that
extra pawn
two porn advantage should be enough what
do you think is going through
sort of maxim's head right now ivanka is
at the tournament situation just
frustrated and disappointed with himself
yeah
i i don't think he's kind of registered
those emotions i think he just knows
that
okay he's lost okay so the only thing
that he's going to go
for is trickster mode he has these two
bishops and
if he can save the game to a draw then
okay he still has one game left to prove
himself
so i think he would just be in trickster
mode where he's just
looking out for the draw yes and levon
arunian
a bit of a decision to make here um so
he did
check with his knight black's king steps
forward white's rook is under attack
white's knight is under attack so both
of those
um pieces are under threat right now he
just needs a way to resolve that tension
so white could trade the rooks here or
he could use his rook to capture the
black bishop with check
a couple of tempting choices both of
them decent i think
personally i would trade those rooks off
and then i would use my knight to go and
try and win some of those black pawns on
the right side
but levon he knows he's got
he's got plenty of choice no right or
wrong answer i think
levon he's spending that time when he
needs to his clock use
maybe going a bit low or maybe going a
bit lower than he'd like to
but he's got things well under control
and we do see the rooks leave the board
and white's knight steps back to try and
aim at those black pawns
on that right side now you did say that
that was maxim's only hope for draw here
that he
traded those rooks off so is it looking
a little bit better for him then
maybe so maybe really very slightly the
problem is is that those
pawns on the right they're so weak you
know you have a bishop attacking them a
knight attacking them
and once the pawns start falling off
then these two bishops are going to find
it very difficult to even generate an
ounce of compensation so it is
very very shaky for maxime yeah there's
only one trick to look out for if we
bring the analysis board up
if white gets too greedy there is a trap
in the position so for example if black
just plays a move which has any move
white should not take this pawn with his
knight this is a trap
if white takes this pawn then actually
that would be a nasty little check here
and this is why bishops are so dangerous
you've got to look out for these traps
this is we call it a skewer
because the king has to move has to move
and the knight will drop at the end of
it so there are traps in the position
um levon aronian of course avoids that
he's about to go two pounds up and he
should win
all right he is in the movie he has less
than two minutes on the clock what
should
uh level well this is what you should do
i guess
yes yes so this is what he's he's doing
our kind of philosophy that we've said
before when you're
losing you should trade pawns and not
pieces and so this is what maxim is
desperately trying to do
he's hoping that perhaps maybe he might
get some kind of opposite color bishop
end games that would be a draw
but uh okay if he he just has to survive
a little bit
and take it to that fourth game hmm
that is mixing watching the groud's only
hope because he did lose
yesterday semi-final match has to win it
today to take it to tie breaks
but uh it's looking like the final will
be
timor jabba versus levonoronian and
that would be an interesting final
fascinating
lots of uh history there like the
players they've played each other so
many times before but also their
countries
azerbaijan and armenia a lot of rivalry
meanwhile level iranian ticking under
one minute now um on the clock he
does want to maintain some of the white
pawns the way that white will win this
game
is to go two pawns ahead and then hope
that he can keep one of his pawns
to promote to a queen later on he needs
to maintain that potential
um with the pawns he does not want to
eliminate supreme pawns we do see
another trade there white has four pawns
black has three but white will go and
win
um one of those pawns now i expect to
see white's knight
go towards the left there and give a
check um
that would be a double attack attacking
the black king and attacking a pawn
but levon aronian he's spending a bit
more time than i thought he would
he's down to 36 seconds and ticking
so he does need to take a decision i
mean the knights are such a crafty piece
okay we have a little trap in the
position this is why nights are so
tricky when you don't have so much okay
well we have some moves
so white attacked the bishop forced it
to retreat the bishop could not take the
pawn
and uh levon is just kind of
consolidating that night he's taking his
time
he's not being greedy at all whatsoever
just maximizing everything he has and
kind of using that principle in the end
game which is
hurry just don't rush and that's why
he's a better player than i am
i would have been very greedy i would
have tried to go for one of black's
pawns
levon says no i'd rather keep that
knight in the middle of the board
look at that dark squared bishop look at
black's dark sky bishop it's completely
blocked in now
it doesn't actually want to trade itself
for that white knight because black
needs to maintain both the bishops
that will be his best chance to use his
two bishops combined on both colour
complexes
um meanwhile maxine bashol grav using
his light squad bishop this time
to attack white's pawn there on the left
corner i expect to see
okay either that pawn might move forward
or white could offer a trade of those
light-squared bishops
if white can trade off one of his pieces
um for
one of those bishops he should be
winning um there we see the pawn
move up the board i mean we did
we did see levon not be greedy and keep
control but maybe he's trying to keep a
bit too much control
is he losing the advantage here i mean i
think he still has a big
big advantage and great winning chances
but i think he had a more direct and an
easier way to win
yeah i i'm i'm just marveling at his
restraint because i would have won some
of those pawns
many moves ago but uh yeah i agree with
you david i think perhaps he hasn't been
so
practical yeah and that actually is
caused by
time trouble and being low on the clock
um i know from my experience i'm often
low on the clock in my games and it's
human nature is human instinct to keep
control you want to keep things
kind of very very rational you want to
keep things
uh you want to be pragmatic you don't
want to take too many risks you don't
want to
put your pieces on squares they might be
attacked but levon aronian he could
earlier have given up a bit of control
in order to grab a pawn and those
having a two-pawn advantage would have
been worth that momentary loss of
control instead
although he's kept that um he's kept
everything nice and coordinated and
balanced
he's still only one pawn ahead and one
pawn in an end game it often isn't
enough
um and levon did shake his head there a
moment ago he knows that maybe
things are starting to slip away um and
uh maxi vacheron
retreating the light squared bishop i'm
surprised by that one that bishop was
perfect in the middle of the board
but bachelor grove putting the pressure
back on
ironian on the clock and aronian
dropping back the white bishop
eyeing up a pawn there on that right
side um
black does have a few weak pawns so
black will not be out of the woods
black will not be able to save this game
any time soon but
um is it another sort of blunder or
well inaccurate why am i similar um it's
not obvious at first to me
um i think white still is in complete
control but white has a problem
if white's bishop zooms up to capture
that pawn on the right side of the board
he'll lose control of his own pawn
on the left flank so going for that
trade
it might it might increase his winning
chances but it also entails
quite a lot of risk yeah i'm expecting
uh lavone
to kind of avoid that you don't really
want to trade pawns i'm expecting him to
protect
his pawn that is vulnerable on the on
the left side
by just protecting it with the knight
you know because
the look of the black bishop that is
there on the right side is completely
blocked in
it's not really doing too much so yeah
try and kind of keep them
some control and put pressure on that
weak
black pawn on the right yeah and um a
big decision there by level aronian
um he's actually allowed a trade of
black's bishop for his knight and we
would have seen opposite color bishops
there but the key was
that he would have won another pawn
opposite color bishops if you're only
one pawn ahead
then nearly no nearly always a draw but
he would have won blacks
one yeah he's finally won a pawn he
finally got the pawn one of the pawns
and now it's the one on the left so now
lavon is two pawns up so yes
he could have won that pawn about 10 20
moves ago so it did take level levon
a bit of a long-winded way a long-winded
approach there to win that pawn so we
see white's two pawns ahead
but if those if blackened somehow get
rid of those three remaining pawns even
at the cost of one of his bishops
he might be able to save the game um so
maximum graph he's trying his best and
he's playing super quickly yeah and you
can just see his uh lavon has just
re-rooted his knight so now the knight
is attacking
the pawn black's only porn and that's
why you're going to see
yeah that's why you're going to see some
kind of pressure now could we get into
opposite color bishop is that going to
be a draw um that would be
uh very difficult to call i think levon
aronian he wants to make sure that
if a bishop and knight get traded he
wants to keep the he wants to
maintain bishops of the same color on
the board it's just
easier to create winning chances if you
have bishops of the same color if you
have bishops of opposite colour
maybe the opponent can blockade on the
same colour
squares as their bishop so big decision
here for levon aronian
what piece do you want to trade off he
goes for the bishops uh
he tries to trade the bishops from the
board um it's always
a huge decision what do you want to end
up with at the end this is why players
they study end games they try to
read books they start they try to play
these types of
positions out because they always know
what they want to aim for
and maxine vazquez says i agree i do not
want to see the bishops leave the board
yeah doesn't want to see the bishops
leave the board and
still you know it was quite a committal
decision to actually remove that bishop
from its protecting square and now again
he oh okay but hang on a second can he
not just take the knight
and take the pawn yeah so black could
actually win back one of the pawns now
but it would be okay he does not go for
that black could have used his dark
squared bishop to capture the white
knight
and then the pawn on the left side
white's left uh
corner pawn it would have fallen so we
would have seen only two
versus one in terms of pawns left there
we do see okay the position has repeated
itself
ironian did repeat moves he tried to
gain that extra 10 seconds on the clock
remember they do gain time after every
move
and now he's shuffling his king across
to that left side he's begging maxine
bachelet graf to
uh trade off the bishop for night he's
giving up
uh level of running he's offering that
pawn at the corner there
oh choice i mean i i'm it doesn't look
to me like it's entirely winning
no i think it's a bluff i think he's
just saying to maxime you can win that
pawn
i'm still going to try and put the
pressure on you after that maxine
doesn't want to go for it though he's
scared of giving up his bishop pair the
two bishops together
which we've said are so strong and i
think maxine he's bluffed himself out of
that decision
he should have gone for it um instead
white is going with an active king right
now
he still has one more chance maxine
vasily grav to capture the white knight
and then go for that corner pawn but
maybe he's left it too late i think he's
left it
and he's gone the wrong direction with
the king um like that king went to the
right side i believe it should have been
going to the left to kind of
to the other black king to kind of
control the left side of the board
and maxine he only has himself to blame
if he loses this
look he's still got eight minutes why
did he not pause that was a key decision
he could have won a pawn back why not at
least stop to think about it
um instead he rushed he just made a move
instantly without thinking
and he does have a losing position
white's knight and bishop now ganging
up against black's remaining pawn in the
middle there um
it does look like white is winning again
levon ironing he's re-established that
control
that he was seeking earlier um vashi
lagrav just rushing too much
yeah so there is still one small little
trick on in the book in that
if you do capture the pawn then this
does
allow black to themselves capture the
pawn on the left side because the knight
is going to be overloaded
yes so um if white currently um
okay white does not choose to capture
that central pawn um that would have
been a trade white would have grabbed
black's remaining pawn but he would have
lost his pawn on the left corner there i
constantly seen that they are
choosing the the wrong moves both of
them so each time they make a move
the bar goes down for them or when makes
it makes a move it goes up for a little
while
that's right and the thing for lavon is
um as the
bar is the computer has always liked
white's position
he's never fully lost control he's
always had the advantage and
um for maxine vachelagrav though on the
other side he is the one who
should be trying to be more accurate
white has this huge margin for error
even if everything goes wrong for white
he still has some winning chances he'll
still have an extra pawn or two
for fashion de grav if things go wrong
for him he will immediately lose the
game
um so that's why i'm surprised maxine is
playing
so quickly he's got so much time on the
clock you know
levon has 43 seconds left and
maxim has just under eight minutes which
is plenty of time to kind of calm it
down
is he falling into that pitfall that
when your opponent doesn't have too much
time you speed up so as not to give your
opponent any chance to think
yeah i think he's just full of that
energy that nervous energy and
um that's just preventing him from kind
of taking those deep breaths maybe you
should follow your approach ivanka have
that mantra to just slow down
occasionally
um black's bishop there going towards
the edge
um levon aronian meanwhile he still has
a winning position
but he hasn't made that much progress he
hasn't shown he's found the winning plan
yet
um so that's what's giving maxine
confidence maybe the fact that irony
he's just maneuvering but
um and his maneuvers though they haven't
actually gained him any time
because you can be forgiven for
maneuvering a lot and just to kind of
give yourself one minute or so on the
clock
but here he's kind of been maneuvering
taking his time with the doing it and
hasn't really made an
improvement in the position like a few
moves ago his position was
so good it was on the verge of
breakthrough and
uh okay we we're going an attempt number
50 i think yeah so this time aronian
he's finally come up with a winning plan
that's to push the white king forward he
the white king wants to step
even further forward right into the
heart of black's position and
take that black pawn um all of white's
pieces the knight the bishop and the
king were aiming towards that black pawn
now
um and therefore maxine rashford as
black stops the further advance
of white's king um aronian
he's back to him he needs a plan and he
needs one quick
so are we in danger actually we're
repeating the position quite a few times
yeah i think oh yeah look at the bar
there and
erroneous he's given maximum the chance
again to trade off
the bishop for the night and then the
black bishop at the top of the board the
light squared bishop could actually
bring itself down
and win black white's corner pawn maxime
he's turned down this opportunity
at least three or four times already so
will he be bluffed
out of that decision again um i must
admit i think i would just go for it now
like i can't stand the nervous tension
now i would just be like
take it just take it and see what
happens okay so we are now what are we
looking for now from maxim to take
the knight with his night okay you can
even throw in a check actually
first just to drive the king one square
backwards and then
capture the light and uh capture the
pawn
it's just uh the thing is though maxim
doesn't actually know that it's bluff
yeah maxine doesn't know that it's a
bluff he still has to evaluate the
position and we look there on just below
the player's cameras
black has two moves to pretty much draw
this game
every other move maintains the whites uh
the white winning advantage
black should either take off that white
knight or give a check
first with his light squad bishop okay
so we are looking for these two moves by
maxim if he finds them
then probably and he does find one of
the best moves ivanka's suggestion
to give check with the bishop the white
king has to step back and now
only one move to hold the game for black
and that's to take off that knight
take off the white knight will maxime
vascular girl find it he's finally
paused spending that time on the club no
he doesn't
he doesn't want to he doesn't know he
doesn't know that it's it's his best
chance
so i mean this is the thing with chess
you know you you the players are not
seeing the computer assessment they have
no access to this
they have to rely on their instincts and
if his instincts is telling to him no
don't do it then
okay he's going to keep on making that
mistake of not grabbing that
pawn and the bar goes back up for lavon
aronian can you find the winning
uh moves this time yeah it's still a lot
of work for iranian and
actually um we are now currently on move
71
on move 52 was the last capture or last
pawn move so
if the players continue in this vein if
they continue another 30 moves without a
capture
or without a pawn move the game will
automatically be declared a draw this is
there's this 50 move rule in chess
um so level of ronin he's got well under
30 moves now
to actually try and find a winning plan
um to go for a trade or to push a pawn
um
and meanwhile it does look he's like
he's still struggling for a plan
meanwhile though maxine vazquez he just
didn't look deep enough he didn't look
long-term enough
the only way black was going to save
this game is to eliminate pawns he
should have gone for that earlier so
what could be the winning plan here for
the phone ironian it seems
that it's so hard for him to get that
white pawn in in the end
uh all the way up there yeah yeah the
black bishop is doing a great job of
stopping that stopping that plan so far
i do think maybe he needs to bring the
white king
round to that left side and guide a pawn
up but in the meantime the problem is he
might have to sacrifice one of his other
pawns
black's king now going for one of those
pawns
we could imagine see a scenario where
black's bishops sacrificed themselves
for all of white's remaining pawns
and then white would only be left with a
knight and a bishop and that's well
known as the most difficult checkmate
in any end game so on an empty board a
king a bishop on the knight versus the
king
these guys don't know how to win it
levon will know how to win it but for
us me immortals other humans club
players beginners it's very difficult to
checkmate that
yeah and that's this is actually a very
interesting point because maxine vashily
grav
is actually attacking one pawn on the
right side of the board he has his king
and his bishop in the action and there
was actually only one
move according to the computer in order
to win
and uh he's missed it you know and
uh now that pawn has gone so this has
got to be
a little bit of some great news for
maxine bachelor he must feel like he can
do it so it's a draw again then
with with best play it's going to be a
draw white is just running out of pawns
and white only has two pawns remaining
and the only way for white to win the
game is to eventually make a new queen
um so that is why levon aronian his
winning chances are starting to
disappear but it's because he left
himself so little time on the clock
he had opportunities i think if he had
five minutes he would have won this game
a long time ago
ten seven seconds now okay and white
comes up with a plan finally he places
his knight on a very odd square
that white knight but it's protecting a
potential advance it's supporting the
advance of
white's corner porn there meanwhile
maxie bachelet grav will he try and stop
the advance of that corner pawn
or will he try and remove white's
central pawn
if he can get rid of white's other pawn
then he knows he has
some room for error he can just
sacrifice his bishop for
uh maybe white's remaining porn this is
really really tense right now
it does look like maximum version of he
should save the game but still a little
bit of work to do
okay um wow imagine if this now goes to
that
that fourth game uh and imagine if
maximizier
is able to win that game and take it to
thai breaks the bonaronian probably will
be a little bit angry with himself well
hang on a second there has been some
progress because we've seen a porn
advance white's porn has just moved one
square closer to promotion and that has
to be
good
yes because that's what that was the
whole battle about it was all about
advancing that pawn and levonian has
done it and and
and what's happening there it looks like
maybe maxine vashti grav
possibly is playing on a laptop and it's
running out of battery and he's rushing
to plug it in
well lucky it's not levon aronian with
only 25 seconds
like simba jayla graham struggling here
too
it didn't look like he was washing the
windows there
i've been there many times sometimes you
suddenly realize you've got five percent
battery left and then
you've got two seconds left on the clock
and you have to decide do you do you
risk it
um meanwhile maxine bachelet he has lost
control as black
and he's missed that last move levon
finding the winning move taking off
black's pawn sacrificing his knight if
black's king
takes that knight now white's central
pawn will march up
and that's a discover check and white
central pawn will win the game maxim
he's got his head in his hands
he missed that last move he has
blundered ironian is about to win
um we saw in this position black's pawn
marching down the board and white just
capturing it
taking this knight now loses whites pawn
marches up
discovered check from the bishop and
this pawn is racing through
white is now in this current position
two pawns up the black king did not take
this knight
but now look at this white has two pawns
white should be winning this game
dramatic game so dramatic and with the
win here le monronian will be ready for
the air things masters final
uh it's getting close it's certainly
getting close
oh and look at the barn out saying 13
advantage for the one here yeah and look
at maxine's face he's covering his eyes
he knows he's messed it up
he just completely missed that night
sacrifice getting rid of black's
remaining porn
um he had the draw so close just in his
fingers
uh and and at his fingertips and yeah
just somehow
he panicked maybe it was because he got
distracted by
having to plug something in um but yeah
he did miss levon's move and levon found
it with seconds on the clock so credit
to him
now there's nothing left to do for black
the problem is he will have to give up
both of his bishops one bishop will
sacrifice itself for the
white central pawn the other bishop will
sacrifice itself for the corner pawn
and we might even see a bishop at night
trying to checkmate a bear king
yeah have you ever done that checkmate
before david i have
the one time i was needed to i did
manage it with one minute left on my
clock
um it is tricky though you do i i think
all top grandmasters even an end game
like that they revise it every six
months every year
just because it's a difficult pattern to
learn how about yourself your anchor
yeah i've done it before and i've
actually mastered a way how to you can
like
just do it like in with anyone can do it
by memory
yeah it's just a pattern recognition you
just have to remember one pattern and
then you have to remember w
i have all these things and you have to
remember box you have to remember the
words
box and then at the end you know and
then you at the end you have to kind of
line up so i i yeah yeah
so every chess player i think needs
techniques to remember things um there's
so much to memorize
in life in chess and you need these kind
of key words these catch words
uh just to trigger the brain yes uh
no doubt aronian he'll he'll have his
own words for that same technique for
the box technique for the w
um but either way aronian he knows he's
winning fascist
he's stopped to think as black but it's
too late
um having four and a half minutes here
will not save him the white pawns
marching down the ball yeah
and it's it's it's also like a great
pawn as well that
he has on the left because it's the same
color
as the bishop the queening square is the
same color as the bishop
so this just means that even if some
pieces do get traded off then
that is the wrong square that is the
right square for this bishop and for
white to win and black
just cannot do anything so it's like
nothing is working
in black's favor yeah that's one thing
these top players do
they always look at the corner pawns and
what color the final square is the
promotion square
so if white's corner porn gets to the
end of the board luckily
it is the same color as his bishop so
that pawn will get support
and there's no way to stop that pawn uh
black meanwhile
fashion grove he just has to fight now
he's thinking
he's been playing so fast entire game
you've been asking him to
to think and now he's thinking but i
guess it's too late it is too late and
that we see
okay one bishop has sacrificed itself
for a pawn
um white central pawn cost black his
light squared bishop
so black only has one bishop remaining
that bishop wants to sacrifice itself
for white's corner
and now you're going to see the white
king start its march to
just escort that porn home and do you
think that we're going to see uh
lebron levon aronian be forced
to mate with the knight and bishop i
hope so i hope we'll see maxine vasily
graf not resign
i want him to play force level on
iranian to go for the checkmate
it's not always easy level ronin he
could push his pawn here
forcing black to there we go we're going
to see this end game night and bishop
versus king
this is a well-known win but it's
difficult it's tricky i love wondering
he's got two minutes on his clock he's
gaining time
um that that capture happened
um on move number um i've even lost
count
base um that that happened on move 92
so white has to win before move 142. oh
wow
you're saying it's a heart it's hard to
find the checkmate channel it's always
easy
no it's not the main thing is that you
just have to know you have to drive the
king to the edge of the board and it
looks like that's what he's doing
yes and you've gotta you you will
checkmate the king there's only one
corner a
corner square two corner squares that
you can check make the king and that's
um
a corner square that is the same color
as your bishop so that is the kind of
technique
and so now here and now here is kind of
my my thing now
now watch the knight the king the bishop
they're lined up together they're lined
in a straight line and now look at the
knight move
it will only move in the w the knight
only moves in the shape of the w
there you go and the bishop is the one
that does the hunting and now we're
going to get a position called
the box if they play are they going to
are they going to show no
wow it is all over the semi-final match
between these two levon
aronian is the winner he will play the
air things monsters
final wow we will have a final with
lavon aronian and timor our job of
iowanka
what will that be like these guys are in
great shape they've been playing the
most fantastic chess i've ever seen
i've been super impressed by both of
them by their calmness
rajabov has impressed with his
brilliance lavon aronian has been so
superior with his strategy in the middle
game i think this is
just going gonna be absolutely riveting
and we did see
uh levon aronian there um not
celebrating very calm
i did see a little smile on his face how
is he feeling now david
yeah he'll be over the moon um i'm sure
he's a very emotional guy and uh he he's
normally not
afraid to show those emotions but yeah
he'll be focused he knows the big one is
ahead
in the final and we are joined now by
the winner of the semi-final lavon
aronia and congratulations how are you
feeling now
thank you guys i am very happy with my
play today
and i'm very happy that i managed to
beat such a strong opponent
fantastic um what has sort of been the
secret for you here in the semifinal
you've been
playing so so good lebron
yeah i was just continuing doing the
same stuff just
taking it easy not stressing too much
so today i think i managed
to do it as well so so far i'm quite
happy
fantastic and yeah david yeah so uh you
might know that you're playing timor
rajabov in the final what are your
experiences like
against him in the past do you have any
match strategy
already prepared uh no i i
tend to think uh like one step at a time
of course he's a tough competitor
and he's very good at this format so i
look forward to the match
so uh i've played him before many times
i think the score is in my favor but
this is a final so everybody is ready
and and how will you be preparing
tomorrow
oh i'll probably do the same what i did
today
you know i'll go for a little run
and come back and continue working
and is panchik watching you well he's
actually sleeping right now
after i finish my games i go there hug
him
and he gives me energy and i come back
he's been the lucky dog for you this
tournament uh
lavon and we actually also saw we've
noticed a ring on your finger looks like
a crocodile is it your
lucky ring this is actually i
i bought this ring uh maybe a week ago
this is actually to remind me of ponchi
because it does look like him
because at times he's aggressive
i mean they didn't have any dogs at the
store where i went but they had a
crocodile so that's uh
a nice uh uh you know kind of
compensation
not having it seems like it's working
very well for you lebanon
uh other than poncho being there and and
this lucky ring
what sort of have you done to become so
good in this online rapid format
come on guys this is just one tournament
well you're playing so good lebron in
the final
well i think i'm not such a bad chess
player
so i'm not surprised myself
but since you guys are surprised i'll
i'll
try to surprise you more we're not
surprised
we are just very very impressed by your
play here
um going to the final now the first
thing that will happen in 2021 playing
the air things monsters final
what does it mean to you oh well
i knew that this is a masters i knew i
had to be ready yeah
so i worked i think
quite a lot considering my standards so
for of
recent so what i mean a lot i mean three
hours a day
so uh yeah i'll uh you know
i'll cherish any chance i'll get so this
is uh
i'm i'm very happy to be in the finals
it's
uh it's a privilege especially when
there are so many strong players
in this tournament so everything
everything else is a bonus
all right um the one we're looking so
much for forward to following you in the
final
as well good luck tomorrow thank you
very much guys
thank you good luck and happy new years
yeah
levon aronian ready for the finals uh
saying that we're we're surprised we're
not surprised but we are impressed
definitely by his
his play and he wasn't one of the
favorites before we started but really
he's really showing off some great chess
in this format
yeah definitely i think maybe he just
had a bit less experience than some of
the other players
just playing online playing with the
mouse you know especially these quick
time controls
over the board he's always been
phenomenally strong and he's just been
able to transfer those skills over and
yeah the two guys in the final they
definitely deserve to be there they
weren't the favorites
but they cruised through to the stage
and the best is yet to come hopefully oh
yes but
okay so this final game that they played
where levon did manage to get that
final win it was such a roller coaster
again
uh winning a draw winning a draw
what was eventually david the winning
plan here
yes so um the key moment actually came
slightly earlier on
and uh maxine vashly graph he just
played too quickly
he missed this next move black pushing
the pawn forward
in the middle he thought as black that
this pawn would give him some counter
play maybe even some chances to win the
game
but this risk that maxine vashtagrav
took it backfired
white captured this pawn taking off
black's remaining pawn and
maxime he suddenly realized that he
could not capture this knight because
suddenly
a discovered check against his king when
the king moves
white's pawn is destined to become a
queen this
gave white a two-pawn advantage and
actually in the final position
i'm going to maybe ask ivanka the
winning plan
at the end the knight and bishop versus
the king in the game
black had to give up both of his bishops
for the pawns and he gave up in this
position he resigned
but how would you win this one ivanka
what would the winning plan be well the
black has to take one step forward
because
that's it so it looks like the king is
out it looks like it's gonna
run away and have all the fun and
yep but uh what you say is no you're in
a
box and now the bishop comes down and
there you go
the king is now in a box and the king
has to take a step
backwards and this is where the knight
only follows the shape of the w so
everything happens with the bishop the
bishop hans so the bishop now takes a
square away that's right
so the king the king steps
wherever and then again you have the
situation where the knight
and the bishop yep and again so
you can yeah we might have to remember
that it's all lined up and now remember
the knight only moves in the w shape so
only kind of jump so that you need your
knight to
yeah it started here right it started on
this square it goes here
yes and then it goes there so the night
will only move
in this this formation and
it only varies when it's about to
deliver checkmate
and uh okay so so david where are you
going to go with the
this way okay so now the bishop hunts so
the bishop cuts off the king
which way do you want to go um nice or
left it doesn't matter
you choose uh yeah maybe not that's
right oh it's okay
not that way okay yes yeah it can go
that way yes
king side steps yes the king side steps
okay so we wait one minute with the
bishop yep
okay and now with the knight gives the
check the w is there in action
i said that now the king has to support
the knight okay so the king has to be
forced to
run and uh yup and
wherever you go yeah okay so the knight
yeah it's bishop no okay bishop check
that's fine okay so now
here is where the knight has done the w
and you have to remember this formation
where the the king and the knight and
the bishop are all lined up
in the same same row so i i like that
one because visually it's really linear
so okay like
[Laughter]
this is the one and then the king moves
okay so the bishop waits so it's gonna
wait
that's that's the square i want and the
king moves again
and so now we check with the knight so
it's broken the knight has broken from
the w
and now the king goes to the corner and
now here is like the linear pattern that
you have to remember
they're all lined up in a row so that
was the final move
this is checkmate yeah yeah the key
thing to remember you want both pieces
actually on the same color square the
bishop
on white squares controlling white
squares the knight on white squares as
well because it controls dark squares
yes
and together they deliver checkmate and
if you remember this is kind of the
things that like a grandmaster described
to me as postcards in your mind and you
should just have the postcard that the
everything starts off on the line and
then you have the box and the knight
only does a w
and then you can kind of recreate that
even if you don't know the exact moves
you're like okay my knight will not move
from the w
only moves from the w to deliver
checkmate and you just remember the
pattern of
the pieces giving checkmate in the line
and then you're like oh
and games can be fun and games can be
fun and complicated
if you ask me now i love whatever only
and did eventually win
this game that they showed here and the
semi-finals
is over team rajabo he beat daniel dubo
both yesterday and today he is the
winner of that semi-final
and he will play the final against lavon
ironian who beat
maxim vagier legram in the semi-finals
okay so after quarter-finals exciting
quarterfinals we did head into these
semi-finals and it ended up with timur
rajabov
and levon aronian being the two
strongest players
they will face each other in the first
major
final in the champions chess tour
all right well the moment we finally
been waiting for all day is finally here
we're
to see david howell try
skiing so he did give a lesson to the
olympic gold medalist in alpine skiing
oxygen swindal
a lesson in chess we seen how that went
he did lose to magnus carlsen obviously
but a good lesson in chester now it's
time
to switch it up and to have excellence
in i'll teach
david howell to ski look at this
you feel ready but looking forward to
this for ages
is that a little slight sarcasm yeah no
bring it on i'm excited 15 years ago i
skied for
less than half an hour i got over
confident i crashed into
my friend's brother he had to get taken
away to hospital in a helicopter
and they said i was a danger to everyone
else
okay well let's try to avoid that this
[Music]
time
[ __ ] sorry i can't even talk my legs are
like jelly
are we actually going down here yeah but
um just to get the uh
to build your confidence a little bit
thank you what we're looking at is
perfect conditions okay so this just has
to work
there's no way it can't work because we
got perfect conditions
thank you i feel more confident now
right one percent more confident yeah
i'll go a few meters first and then you
can follow okay
so i put pressure on this foot
okay and then it takes me back just so
how do i start i just
forward and pressure on the left
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i get an image how you guys feel
watching me play chess because obviously
you look like a
beginner right sure but this is exactly
the same this is how i look on the
chessboard
okay good point do you feel like a
disappointed teacher though that
i'm still at a beginner level
so axel i've been thinking can i give it
one more shot
yeah i love that you're not giving up
chinese never give up you feel ready for
this right
bring it on
yeah i don't think that last one was
david oh don't you
you got good at the end ivanka where's
your faith in me
oh that was oh i'm so glad that wasn't
me yeah was crying with embarrassment
it was such a fun day though one of the
best days of my life and he was amazing
such a nice guy
imagine an olympic champion being so
patient um
yeah he really kind of got me into it
that's my new year's resolution
to get better this year fantastic anyone
else on twitter seeing this
yeah we have a beautiful picture
from a female nurse who says
go david and there you are on your skis
getting good skiing across the slopes
yes uh fantastic and we are also now
joined by
ginger gm simon williams simon what's
your verdict
on david howell the skier yeah it
makes it look so natural doesn't even
smooth
some very smooth moves that he's doing
down the slope
um yeah maybe maybe stick to the chest
i might have been i'm really joking it
was it was really fun a really fun clip
and it looked like you had a great time
there as well so that's the main thing
right
are you are you sort of are you happy
now david
we've shown it i'm done yeah it's done
it's out there for the wide world to
laugh at and enjoy and um yeah i'll be
sticking to the chess
yeah sure and ivanka said it uh you
looked so good in the end there
um it wasn't you was it no
let's take a look how david really got
down um
from there
[Laughter]
snowball yeah simon are there any uh new
skills you want to learn in 2021
ah i'm i i wanted to actually try
learning the piano
um after watching a bit of piano music
last night but i don't know if i'll get
around to that um
and yeah i'm skiing i'm i'm not sure
about skiing he made it look so hard
there
i think i'll probably stay away from the
slopes i think good idea
all right we're simon um we have to talk
about the chess as well wow we have the
final now with teamwork java
and levon aronian what's your reaction
to that
i think it's gonna be a great final i
mean they've they've both played the
best chess
and the most exciting chess they deserve
to be there
um they got quite sort of different
styles so you got
um i think aronian who's who's quite
solid and he's just playing very high
quality
he's not really taking too many risks
and you've got rajabov who
tends to take more risks and plays in a
bit more of a tactical manner so it's
kind of a little bit of a clash
of styles and uh yeah it's going to be
very exciting
and we had a super exciting day it's
over quite early
both of them managing to win their
semi-finals quite
fast here but you did have you do have
some favorite uh moment from today don't
you simon
yeah definitely i mean i think the sort
of first game
is where the pace for the day was set um
and this was about early as move five
here
and you had a dupe off with the white
pieces and rajput
obviously with the black side and
normally when you're white it's kind of
like you can play in a safe manner you
don't have to take too many risks
um but do boss just not that kind of guy
you know he's just like a bit of a
lunatic
and uh i think he wanted to start 2021
on a high
with some very ingenious ideas and then
in this position he plays a really
rare move he goes g4
and this is just like a cake we call it
a caveman move
it's literally no nothing refined about
it is get the club
and just run at your opponent's king and
just that on move five just the fact
that it's only been played like maybe a
dozen times
in the history of chess means that it's
really really rare but
you're also weakening your own position
by doing this lunge because the white
king where's the white king gonna go now
normally you want a castle
kingside but if the white king does
castle kingside
you've kind of lost one of your
bodyguards your g pawn gary the g
pawn has run away from your king so it's
incredibly double-edged and then
if we move a little bit later on maybe
to move 15
it was really heating up and i kind of
feel this was maybe
a key moment and we see that black has
just pushed
his two pawns next to each other in the
middle and
i i was wondering this situation if
white could have
now done another aggressive idea and
duboff is
most aggressive player and played bishop
a3 here
and this move kind of looked very
interesting to me attacking the rook
and let's say that rook now moves out of
the attack the rook is worth
five points and here now you bring your
rook
into the center of the board so every
move you're trying to create
a fret and let's say that queen moves
because otherwise you'll lose your queen
and here another strong move the bishop
comes in with check
in the center of the board and this is a
position where black has to be
really careful for example if the king
tries to hide
in the corner which is a normal idea
because your king normally is safe in
the corner of the board in the middle
game
well white has a sparkling idea that
knight
on the edge of the board normally bads
have a knight on the edge of the board
can jump in with check and after it
jumps in with check
this is a lovely way to finish the game
the pawn has to take the knight
and now look at that rook in the corner
the rook in the corner hasn't done
anything so far but all of a sudden
after pawn takes pawn
it unleashes itself into check not just
check but check
mate so um i was kind of wondering about
that long sequence and
i'm sure black could improve the play
somewhere but maybe that was worth
trying anyway it looks like a a good
a good way to keep the initiative going
all right one fantastic moment
of today and uh well we're done with the
semi-finals heading into
finals uh simon uh we actually we have a
twitter quiz going on today and it's
about
super powers now what super power would
you most like to have
i'm well i said you always throw me on
the spot it's great
about that sorry i i would i would kind
of like
you know stopping time would be quite
cool that's quite i think you know sort
of just being able to
i could spend like you know two weeks on
a chest position then and i'd make sure
i get the right move
probably better uses for that superpower
so uh maybe yeah maybe some
time distortion or something would be
quite a cool one for me uh what do you
guys go for
i want to fly i want to fly i want to
read people's minds
and david i just want to get better at
skiing so i don't fall
on my bottom every day just better
balance maybe
better okay simon wow super exciting day
and coming up tomorrow
uh thank you for joining us again today
thank you and happy new year to everyone
as well so uh did you guys celebrate did
you get any
or was it nice and professional i'll let
david answer that
we are we are very professional but we
did see some fireworks
luckily how about yourself simon well
obviously the lockdown i mean i had had
some drinks at home and stuff
so it was yeah it was a nice tame
celebration
let's hope for more celebration in the
new year 2021 i hope it's going to be a
good year simon
yeah it will be exactly perfect all
right we'll talk to you again tomorrow
when the final starts
okay i'll see you in the final bye all
right
some superpowers ivanka that was the
theme of the quiz today
that was the theme and uh yeah we asked
and
you at home and twitter delivered we
have some really cool
answers um one that i really liked was
simone madeo says
chess super power slow time down
similar kind of vein to simon finally i
can evaluate
way more difficult positions and then
another one
is jackie the alien my superpower is
just being myself i really do not have
the need fantastic i think
more and uh then there's another one
from
siren dalsberg my pockets are
a different dimension this is i like the
randomness here
when i withdraw my hand from my pocket
anything can be in it
i love it mary poppins and then one
which i
really really liked uh this is from kai
reimers he says i would like to have the
combined powers of
jesus and a superman simon williams
being
jesus and david how old me
being superman it's simon jesus because
of the beard
yeah that's right and uh yeah clark kent
here
but the winner is jesus
this is actually someone that we've
actually supported this course jesus
medina molina he says
i would like to have the super power to
spread chess tables to all parks in the
world
so that all kids can see learn and play
chess
i do know that jesus actually has a
campaign going to actually
introduce more chess sets fantastic i
love that
a very dessert winner definitely and
yeah jesus you are the lucky winner of
our air things device
and someone will be contacting you for
your details
but congratulations congratulations so
fantastic superpower
great okay uh we're done with semifinals
final predictions for the final who's
going to be the winner of the air thanks
masteries
i'm going to have to say rajaborf what a
jedi you know he
was able to just be like the chameleon a
change
kind of style you he saw it against
dubois he just went
solid we saw him be aggressive against
napoli actually and
moreover we saw him being so cool
under time pressure i've never seen the
like all right how about you david
yeah i'm gonna have to disagree i'm
gonna have to say aronian it just feels
like
somehow he's back at his best he was
world number two for so long
such a classy guy and he can beat anyone
on his day feels like he's peaking at
the right peaking at the right moment
all right we are done with semifinals
the final of their things monsters is
coming up tomorrow now we enjoyed
spending the first day of 2021 together
with all of you we're looking forward to
keep it going tomorrow with some more
exciting chances to come
the final of their things monsters will
start tomorrow
hope to see you then goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
you